logan experience joy my day Joe Rogan
podcast by night and we're live
gentlemen here we go again what's
happening back in the room a pleasure to
see you guys as always this is one of my
favorite podcasts that we ever do and
this is very timely because first of all
the big New York Times article about the
possibility of a comet hitting Los
Angeles the preparations for what they
would do if a comet hit Los Angeles and
the comet known as Donald Trump that's
hit the United States and he's even got
the hair it's just the whole things I
mean if the end of the world was coming
boy it's all on the wall you know the
writings all there it's kind of crazy
mm-hmm so what's the latest and the
greatest well the latest and the latest
and the greatest is like I mean last
year when we sat down with you I think
it was last November mmm yeah it was
almost a year got floated in the
discussion the idea that this really
important comet research that's going on
which is just changing our whole view of
history and prehistory and of the future
of humanity but it would be good to make
a film about this and crowdfunded I
actually mentioned that to the
scientists and they said what we really
need is more funding for our research
and so they've inspired by basically by
your show they have put out a
crowdfunding campaign which is linked on
my on my website it's the comet research
group and it's it's a big story right
now so how can people find it really
quickly it's IndieGoGo well now that
research much quick away just go just go
to my website Oh Graham Hancock calm and
there's a revolving banner which is the
comet research group click on that and
you're in this beautiful ok Graham
Hancock calm and then crowd funding for
comet research and so what are they were
trying to put together well they're
they're wanting to see the thing is
these guys have actually not had any
official funding this is a group of
major highly credentialed scientists who
for the last decade have been
investigating the extraordinary story of
a massive comet series of comet impacts
on the North American ice cap twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago that is
the the global Cataclysm that wipes out
a whole civilization
from from prehistory so that's why it's
of interest to me they're not coming at
it from that point of view they're
coming at it from rediscovering
something that we've lost about
ourselves something is really important
to understand the role of cataclysms in
the story of the earth and they need to
do much more research they need to go
back to Greenland and look for the nano
diamonds in the in the Greenland ice
cores they need there's a there's an
ancient city which they're not revealing
the name of which they're pretty certain
was wiped out by a comet impact about
four and a half thousand years ago they
want to go there and investigate that so
there's a lot of fieldwork they need to
do to drive home this hypothesis and to
frankly put down the opposition because
there's been so much opposition to this
idea from people with vested interest in
other theories that that's why these
guys have not got funding so the only
place they're going to get funding to do
this further research is from members of
the general public and that's what we're
hoping that will will happen it's called
the comet research group there's a
banner on my site and all the links are
there to their crowdfunding to their
website which is full of masses of
scientific information and to their
Facebook page as well it is a very
unusual thing the the fact that we know
that comets and all sorts of various
large objects have impacted the earth we
see the craters we know they exist but
it's so rarely discussed it's so it's so
strange if it wasn't for this article in
the New York Times I can't remember one
the last time and that it even came up
and it's such a huge issue
it's a massive issue it's a massive
issue both Randall and I have really you
know given a great deal of thought to
there's nothing rattled you that the
point is that catastrophes are the
untold story of our past we were given a
little we're givers a little hint of it
February of 2013
Chelyabinsk siberia reverie of it yeah
yeah now that was just a little cosmic
spec came in I was about fifty feet in
diameter which is about um and it came
in at a fairly low angle it blew up
nearly eighteen get that thing right in
front you right in front of me like this
yeah if you flat it out it's usually
easier how's this just better yeah all
right there we go so it came in I think
it exploded twelve miles about 20
kilometers up in the atmosphere but it
still enough to damage thousands of
buildings and injure 1500 people another
thing about that one is if it had been
slightly larger if it had come in at a
slightly steeper angle a little bit
higher velocity you could have had
thousands of fatalities rather than just
injuries and that would have been major
headline news at that point as it was
it's already forgotten but you do
remember yes oh yeah oversee we may even
talk I've talked I believe indeed we did
I think most videos of it you know it's
fascinating is Russia has so many of
those trail cam and nut trail cam um
dash cam photo cameras that's right
because they have so much insurance
fraud apparently over there slam into
each other all the time and they want to
record it so we're fortunate enough to
have so many of those videos because of
that which puts it on the record whereas
other otherwise it would it would not be
I think I think people don't they don't
like to talk about cataclysms and
catastrophes and actually nor do I
nobody wants a horrible Cataclysm to
occur but this is the point which is
that the prospect of a comet or asteroid
Cataclysm on the earth is actually much
higher than has been told to us up till
now and something can be done about it
it doesn't have to be the end of the
world we don't have to you know say okay
it's all over forget about it quite the
contrary this is this is just something
that would be prudent and rational for
the human species to do and amongst many
other imprudent and irrational things
that we focus on instead we should be
focusing on a bit on this well at least
just to heighten awareness of it and and
also the possibility that we've been
nailed a bunch of times and we've
forgotten about it and this is this is
the big thing that you've been dealing
with your entire career this skepticism
about past civilizations I mean I got
into it with Michael Shermer who's a
friend of mine who's a very famous
skeptic I got into him with it yesterday
because I posted that you were going to
be on and he started chirping something
about civilizations 12,000 years ago
where's the evidence on like to do you
don't even you're saying this and you
don't even know about gobekli tepe so I
sent him gobekli tepe and literally like
five hours later he wrote something
claiming that while that was made by
hunter-gatherers it was all just really
to sort of suit he
narrative so he doesn't know that no one
knows nobody knows that they're so
determined to keep the existing model
and and when new evidence comes in which
can't be explained by the existing model
they just try to explain away the new
evidence and not not think maybe it's
time to change our theory you know this
is this is the unfortunate thing but
cataclysms a global Cataclysm the
massive event that happened twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago the
Younger Dryas impacts which were a
series of comet impacts on the north
american ice cap this accounts for why
we don't have a lot of evidence hard
evidence over 12,000 plus year old
civilization because it went down in
that catastrophe it was wiped out I've
been trying to amass the evidence
actually that complements what Graham is
doing and it really answers that
question the Schirmer brought up and
it's a legitimate question where where's
the evidence but I'm quite sure the
Schirmer is not really educated in the
extreme events that have really taken
place on this planet in the last ten to
twenty thousand years um and what that
would do to any kind of evidence it
maybe while we have some time here today
I've brought a few things to try to
convey some sense of how extreme some of
these changes have been and how one
would actually be quite shocked to find
anything existing in the aftermath of
these events well Michael Shermer is a
brilliant guy and I don't mean the [ __ ]
on him but but what what is disturbing
to me is that his knee-jerk reaction to
this without having any research at all
in the subject not knowing at all about
gobekli tepe which was discovered in
what the 90s
yeah 96 I mean so this is to me this is
something that I've looked at because of
you guys in great depth when I read your
book I was just completely enthralled
with this idea of history having some
sort of or rise and fall and
civilization having these resets so I've
been absorbed in it for a long time but
what's fascinating to me is people that
consider themselves to be skeptical or
you know or I mean he's a skeptic
professional insurer but many people who
question anything that's outside of what
they've been told as soon as they hear
any sort of a theory outside of what
they were told they immediately call
quackery happy anything and this but
it's it's a weird knee-jerk reaction to
something especially when you talk about
asteroids that is
very real part of our past we have a ton
of evidence I mean there's actual
craters that you can look at on earth
the moon which has no atmosphere is
littered with them and if we look at the
moon as a model for what could possibly
have happened to earth or at least you
know some of them obviously with the
moon having no atmosphere it's going to
get hit a lot more than we are sure but
still I mean this is a very real
situation that this this solar system
you know at least as far as we know the
only solar system has to deal with this
but we know this is a real issue maybe
we've seen impacts what it's like you
just said on the one hand you have earth
scientists looking at the earth and what
they're realizing is that the earth is
pockmarked with scars and each of these
scars represents a tremendously powerful
catastrophe that's happened in the
history of the earth
now that's accepted by mainstream
science that that major catastrophes
have happened in the history of the
earth but where this thing now is about
to come full circle is the recognition
that these kinds of catastrophes have
also influenced the rise and fall of
civilization and a lot more a lot more
extremely than then has been recognized
up to this point and while geologists
and earth scientists are looking at the
surface of the earth and realizing that
itched into the surface of the earth or
imprinted into the surface of the earth
are hundreds of scars of which
undoubtedly are only a small percentage
of the total that exist at the same time
astronomers are looking out into
near-earth space and discovering that we
cohabit space with a lot of stuff it's
not as empty as we thought just within
the last six or seven weeks we've had
two close flybys of previously
undiscovered that really of previously
undiscovered asteroids this the point is
NASA keeps saying well is you know
there's we've counted 1,650 asteroids
and none of them are going to hit the
earth in the next hundred years well
yeah that's true but what about all the
ones they haven't counted which are
estimated to run into hundreds of
thousands and which haven't been seen
yet and what happens is we see them
roughly ten days before they pass the
earth that is not enough time to do
anything about them but we have time if
we're prepared to be rational and
reasonable as a civilization to take
care of this issue now when you're
dealing with hundreds of thousands of
near-earth objects that are flying
around like what what are the things
that could be done
to protect Earth you can paint it's it's
low-tech actually you can paint one side
of the asteroid affect its albedo so
that the sun's rays push differentially
on one side rather than the other that
will shift its orbit slightly it has to
be calculated you can give it a little
knock with with with a rocket basically
you don't want to blow it up
you don't want to turn you know you're
one big piece of our artillery shell
into buckshot you don't want to do that
you want to you want to move it into a
safer orbit you can mount jets on it
people are looking now to mining
asteroids of course our society always
goes our civilization always goes for
the where weather where the money's to
be made but yeah if we can mine
asteroids we can move asteroids and and
the technology is there and ironically
the most dangerous asteroids are going
to be the ones that are the closest to
the earth which are the most accessible
and the asteroids pretty much have
unbelievable amounts of resources on
them I mean pretty much everything that
is being mined on the earth can be found
in asteroids from the hydrocarbons to
precious metals to all of these things
and we're not that far away from
technologically being able to actually
you know mount expeditions to asteroids
and mined them and that's that's the the
you know that's the solution I kind of
prefer because again these things are
tremendous sources of reefs of all kinds
of things that would be usable to an
expanding civilization and we could
feasibly within a decade or two be
mining asteroids and again the ones that
are the easiest to access are also going
to be the ones that are more dangerous
because they're the ones that are coming
the closest to the earth so and another
point here is that there is one specific
danger there's one specific if you like
region of the sky that really needs to
be looked at and this is this is the
region of the sky this is why I wrote
magicians of the gods because because of
this discovery that there's a thing
called the torrid meteor stream which is
30 million kilometres wide and which
envelops the solar system and the earth
on its orbit around the Sun passes
through the torrid meteor stream twice a
year turns out the torrid meteor stream
is the debris
of a giant comet that came in to the
inner solar system about 20,000 years
ago that thing was at least a hundred
kilometers in diameter according to
their calculations it may have been more
so and then like other comets like
shoemaker-levy 9 which spectacularly hit
Jupiter in 1994 it began to break up
into multiple fragments and those carry
on orbiting on the original path which
and as they break up more and more they
degrade and small bits and large bits
break off and it gradually fills up a
kind of huge hoop of debris that the
earth is passing through twice a year it
takes us 12 days to pass through it we
do two and a half million kilometres a
day on our orbital path 12 days to get
through the torrid meteor stream and the
scientists of the comet research group
have made the point that a big object
out of the torrid meteor stream multiple
objects as a matter of fact was what hit
the North American ice cap twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago it
looks like there was a second series of
impacts eleven thousand six hundred
years ago from the same source it looks
like there were other impacts in the
Bronze Age the most recent almost
definite impact out of the torrid meteor
stream was Tunguska in Siberia back in
1908 that hit on the 30th of June 1908
and that's at the peak of the torrid
June shower when we passed through the
tories in June and and in November and
what they're saying is we really need to
focus on this torrid meteor stream their
calculations are that there are hundreds
and hundreds of massive objects in that
torrid meteor stream and you know as a
comet breaks up into bits
it becomes those bits become asteroids
and those asteroids are circling in the
torrid media stream and I've likened it
to strapping on a a blindfold and
crossing an eight-lane interstate twice
a year and just hoping that we don't hit
any heavy traffic you know that we meet
bicycles or motorcycles rather than
rather than trucks but the trucks are
out there and what the comet research
group scientists are saying is we need
now to be in depth investigating the
torrid meteor stream because it appears
to be the hidden hand in human
civilization it has wiped out episodes
of our history in the past and there's
no reason to expect that it won't do so
again unless we do something about it
because the remnants of that original
giant comet
still circling in the torrid media
stream and they are [ __ ] dangerous
now how is this being received in
mainstream science I mean is there any
resistance to this because it seems like
this is all pretty straightforward and
entrer scible mostly being ignored
mostly being ignored why I think that is
by scientists who have a vested interest
in other ideas first of all there's a
vested interest in not admitting that
cataclysms are important at all this
goes right back to really to the 19th
century when science began to take shape
in the form that we know it now and they
wanted to separate themselves off
understandably from superstition so I
didn't want anything to do with
something that sounds like the Biblical
Flood
for example they felt they would be
contaminated by that and they preferred
to explain any cataclysmic evidence as a
result of gradual processes so you
really think it's because of the
reluctance to accept religion or
religious ideas or to to separate
themselves I think that was the stuff
where it started or it started to
separate themselves off from that now
they've gone a long way from that and
many many scientists have got a vested
interest in what is called
uniformitarianism or gradualism and they
they don't like to hear about cataclysms
having any major impact on the story of
life on earth so is it sort of the
momentum of these initial desires to
escape religious influence that have
sort of led them down this path yes and
then there are others who have a vested
interest in current accounts of global
warming there's others who have a vested
interest in extinctions taking place now
they want to say that our ancestors were
responsible for the extinction of all
the mammoths and mastodons and so on and
so forth whereas the comet research
group scientists are saying no those
huge megafauna of North America were
wiped out as a result of the massive
series of impacts on the North American
ice cap I'm reading a book right now by
Dan Flores a really interesting book
called coyote America he's a wildlife
historian and he is really an expert on
all the different forms of Wildlife in
North America where they originated were
they migrated to and one of the more
fascinating things about it is he's
talking about all these animals that
went extinct you know ten thousand plus
years ago this mass extinction event and
never once does he bring up cataclysms
and and there's all these different
these different ideas and one of the big
being that human beings with addle addle
x' which is like really a very weird
sort of a spear throwing device wiped
out the woolly mammoths and all these
other animals and to me a posture it's a
lunatic idea also if you have any
contact with hunter-gatherers today you
find that hunter-gatherer peoples don't
over kill their game they they hunt them
respectfully they take what they need
and they leave the rest because it's a
renewable resource for them so I don't
think hunter-gatherers wiped out the the
mammoths in North America the evidence
is compelling it was the comedy well the
evidence that you brought up when you
were here the first time when you showed
the images of all those mammoths that
had been literally knocked over with
broken legs from the impact of something
on a mass burial grounds like these mass
did you know and not burial grounds
obviously but mass casualties mortality
sights mortality sites cool yeah that's
a good way of putting it yeah in fact
graham i visited one up in south dakota
called hot springs where there's just
several dozen nobody knows how many are
actually there but there's at least
several dozen two species woolly
mammoths and Colombian mammoths that
have been entombed and while we were
there I interestingly I you know the the
guide the woman giving us the tour there
was kind of giving the a gradualist
explanation at well over long periods of
time these mammoths wandered into a
sinkhole and were too dumb to get out
and so they became entombed and I asked
the question well what studies have been
done on the the sedimentary matrix in
which their remains are being found
because as I'm looking at this
sedimentary matrix I'm seeing a massive
deposit that in other words a deposit
that was instantaneous instantaneous and
when I brought that up she actually got
very irritated and wailing you all yet
dismissed my question didn't you know
what we've got it all worked out you
know we we know about that well what is
it
well you just we've got it all worked
out and it immediately went on with her
like but yet I had an article that was
actually written by one of the original
scientists worked on the site and he his
description was well it could have been
that but also as an alternative and he
used the term bloat and flow
that what you had was woolly mammoths
that had been caught in a flood drowned
and they're bloated carcasses floated
into a depression in the landscape and
that's where they were entombed and that
makes a whole lot more sense to me than
the fact that you know individually over
several thousand years these in these
mammoths wandered into this sinkhole and
then couldn't get out but you got to
bear in mind we're talking about you
know at the end of the last ice age a
hundred and twenty roughly species of
megafauna that disappeared which is
about equivalent to the same number of
megafauna species that inhabits the
earth today well as a short period of
time was something like 65 percent of
the North American mammals went extinct
75 / 75 percent a very short period of
time or a very short period of time
pretty much totally coincident with that
period called the Younger Dryas and so
there's nothing resembling what we're
capable of doing today back then I mean
when you look at human extinction events
human caused extinction events was very
logical and what we're doing today with
pollution and the expanse of
civilization and weapons are super
sophisticated if we wanted to we could
wipe out a lot of different species yeah
but what we're out of the least the case
actually seeing is that at the end of
what's called the balling allarod which
was the gradual warming at the end of
the last ice age that preceded the
sudden catastrophic change at 12,800 was
a de Clovis culture that existed for
three to five hundred years I think yes
somewhere but they suddenly were gone
right exactly simultaneous with the
mammoths and then there are interesting
studies that coming out now showing that
at least continental wide there was
apparently a major human population
crash exactly coincident with the
megafauna extinctions because you had
quarries that had been mined for
centuries that are suddenly abandoned
you have campsites that had been that
had generations of debris and toolkits
accumulating and so on debris from the
from the the fluting of the the spear
points and so on that are suddenly
abandoned right so the evidence actually
suggests that the human population
crashed which would certainly imply that
they would been far less capable of
wiping out all of these species of
MegaFon
also the the studies of their diet and
their life ways suggest that they were
very quite diverse they were
hunter-gatherers and they focus mostly
on small game they ate a lot of fish lot
of shellfish they gathered food and why
would they go after the biggest most
dangerous animal you know in the in the
whole in the whole array of animals and
with the incredible efficiency hunt them
to extinction in a hundred years it
doesn't make sense no it makes no sense
it seems pretty silly it mean ancestors
from that time if I may say Randall
mentioned the Clovis culture this is for
a very long time really until just a
couple of years ago all of the
mainstream academics in the fields of
archeology and anthropology were saying
there were no human beings in North
America before let's say 13,000 years
ago give or take five hundred years and
they came across the Bering Land Bridge
the Bering Strait at that time was above
water sea level was lower they entered
the Americas then they weren't hit there
before now in the last two to three
years there's just been a whole raft of
new scientific research and no scientist
today is prepared to defend the Clovis
model anymore it's accepted of course
that they've been human beings in
America for 50,000 60,000 years and
there's weird genetic links like for
example there's a trace that connects
Aboriginal Australians with North
Americans they had a common ancestor
it's a very peculiar thing that's going
on and so what what happens is that
actually these scientific models which
constrain and restrict research for so
long do get overthrown and that Clovis
model is being overthrown and what the
missing piece of the puzzle puzzle I
think for everybody working this field
is the Cataclysm the comet what happened
between twelve thousand eight hundred
and eleven thousand six hundred years
ago which changed everything
is it the bizarre to you guys or
frustrating in any way that this is not
a mainstream idea this is this very much
fringe but yet it's it's not something
that we don't have any evidence whenever
whenever I put out a book I'm I
immediately there's this huge hostile
reaction like the Michael Shermer thing
like the Michael Shermer thing like me I
mean I would say magicians of the gods
which I published in 2015 which deals
with this whole comet issue is actually
the most thoroughly
documented the most thoroughly
referenced book that I've ever written
it's calm its measured they actually
don't read it they just say Oh Hancock's
brought out another book he's a
pseudo-scientists that's what they
always call me or a pseudo archaeologist
and and it's obviously rubbish because
it disagrees with everything that we
know well that's the point of the
heretic in society is to offer an
alternative view and and well-documented
evidence but it seems that we're dealing
with such a deeply ingrained mindset
which is connected in curious ways to
power structures in our society that
it's very difficult to change it
absolutely like graham mentioned earlier
there's kind of a poet it went from a
religious motive I think in the 19th
century and now it's more a political
motive and again the idea that every day
you'll find something you know coming
from various factions that were
destroying the earth and the earth has
never suffered this kind of you know
assault on it before and and you know
we're causing the sixth great mass
extinction and we're going to cause
catastrophic global warming if we pump
another 50 or 100 parts per million of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere and
and so what that is done is like many I
won't say many but several of the
scientists now that have been in the
forefront of criticising the Younger
Dryas impact hypothesis are also very
much involved in the global warming
movement and the idea that we are now
precipitating the sixth great mass
extinction having looked now at mass
extinctions and been really an obsession
of mine for about thirty years now I've
looked at everything from the
cretaceous-tertiary the Permian Triassic
you know right on down the line to the
most recent one which to me is really in
some ways the most interesting because
the most recent mass extinction that
we're talking about is the one that took
place while we humans were were part of
the of the story and between twelve
thousand eight hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred years ago the
Younger Dryas yes the Younger Dryas
which is still an unexplained climate
anomaly that happened and I mentioned
this I think in previous broadcast that
you know what you had was you had just
spasm of extreme warming followed by
rapid shifting into extreme cold
literally within a matter of a few years
and we're talking about climate changes
that are up to 15 degrees Fahrenheit
within perhaps 1 to 5 years which uh
turley Dwarfs anything that we've
experienced in the last since the
industrial revolution began and we still
don't really understand and that's why
this research is so important because
now we understand that there was
something cosmic that happened it's left
its imprint in the landscape over what
four continents five continents yeah
over over 50 million square kilometers
of the Earth's surface there's a giant
debris field of the this stuff that is
only produced by massive impacts these
things come in at 70,000 miles an hour
and you know if they have any diameter
at all if they're if they're 100 meters
or more in diameter they are they are
going to hit the earth really hard
they're not going to burn up in the
atmosphere and when they do they pack a
huge amount of kinetic energy a huge
amount of heat and shock and that
creates very definite chemical products
so nano diamonds so Carbon spherules so
melt glass that's like the Trinitite
that was produced in nuclear explosions
all of these when they're all found
together in the same layer of soil and
when you can put a date on that layer of
soil and when it's all over the world
there's only one thing can explain them
a massive cosmic it I don't understand
why this is controversial I really don't
I mean I do I understand it because I
know that once people start teaching
things once people start doing lectures
and giving speeches they want to stick
to their guns and they want to they want
to somehow or another avoid anything
that's going to contradict what what
they've been espousing it's a game this
is a game changer this information it
changes everything
it changes the way we've looked at our
past it changes the whole story of
archaeology and it changes the way we're
going to look at the future and I think
that people in academia are reluctant to
embrace that change and they're afraid
of being called pseudo scientists
because there's a whole lobby of
skeptics who use this word pseudo
scientist or pseudo archeologist as an
instant dismissal of other ideas and
those who are in the profession they
don't want to get tarred with
that brush they want to keep themselves
clean and I understand that but you're
talking about hard evidence yeah you're
talking about this nuclear glass you're
talking about nano diamonds you're
talking about core samples that show
this massive shift when you do the ice
core samples massive shift in
temperature and you're talking about
very clear evidence of impacts that we
know exist it's not like a comet's a
theory that's not like it's Bigfoot or
something like you know we're looking
for the final piece of evidence it shows
that comas real thing exactly it's real
it's Toth it's totally real but it's so
difficult for those who are invested in
other models to accept and unfortunately
they have the ear of the media it's the
it's there are or by the way all the
scientists in the comic comet research
group are absolutely mainstream
scientists and they have taken a lot of
flack from their colleagues for even
daring to investigate this area that's
why they've had no funding they've had
to fund themselves it's so well that is
so crazy because this is not a
controversial thing in my mind shouldn't
be it should not be this is not an
airy-fairy thing we're not talking about
psychics we're not talking about UFOs
we're talking about something we know
exists yeah so to bury your head in the
sand over something like this seems to
me invested in a process is interest
right now NASA is spending the
equivalent of one attack helicopter a
year on investigating the the Comet and
asteroid danger you know 50 million
dollars a year that's not that much it's
peanuts
it's a tiny it's a miniscule some
hundreds of billions of dollars on on
massive sophisticated military equipment
which we can use to slaughter one
another in ever more sophisticated ways
but just fifty million dollars a year on
saving the earth from from a potential
Cataclysm that could put our
civilization back into the Stone Age
tomorrow and I don't mean to keep
harping on Michael Shermer because I
like microwave but that he highlights
this sort of natural inclination to poke
fun at something that he has done no
research on whatsoever when I pointed
out gobekli tepe and I sent him some
articles from National Geographic
he went radio silent mm-hmm I mean he
should know about it it's astonishing
the people mocking it yeah he's gonna
mock it you should actually know what
you're mocking and to say that Gobekli
Tepe was created by hunter-gatherers
what I'm sorry that's just
theory that's not it that's not a fact
you seem very very sophisticated site
with astronomical alignments with
hundreds and hundreds of megalithic
pillars weighing up to 20 tons each the
world's first perfectly aligned
north-south building which you can only
do with astronomy this is it's not
enough to say oh they were just
hunter-gatherers there was something
strong from a half a mile away I mean
there's there's some serious
sophistication I mean what how big were
these stones well the the biggest one
actually still in the quarry they left
it because it had a fault in it they
clearly intended to move it 50 tons
you're looking at 20 foot high objects
and then it's the it's the putting
together of them see here's the problem
hunter-gatherer societies are not the
kinds of societies that produce
large-scale fixed monuments why because
they don't generate a surplus you can't
pay for somebody to become an architect
and for it
of those times somebody become an
astronomer you're busy hunting and
gathering and that's what you do
agriculture generates a surplus and
that's the bat is the problem at gobekli
tepe because there is no background this
site just appears out of nowhere amidst
what appears to be a hunter gatherer
community but what they're not
considering is the possibility we're
looking at a technology transfer that
the survivors of a lost civilization who
already had all that knowledge came to
go back Lee Tepe and use that site as a
center of initiation to teach the local
hunter-gatherers how to do agriculture
and that's now taken as the beginnings
of civilization I would say it is the
reinvention or the remaking of
civilization so when we're looking back
at Sumer and any artifacts we find
ancient Mesopotamia in that area Iraq
those are the people that are sort of
reinventing and relearning well that's
hence Oliver actually when we talk of
Mesopotamia which means between two
rivers the Tigris and the Euphrates
gobekli tepe is sitting right there in
the headwaters between the Tigris and
the Euphrates and we cannot separate
that from the later cultures that enter
history five thousand six thousand years
ago they're part of the lineage that
descended from gobekli tepe times and
what's fascinating about gobekli tepe is
the way it doesn't fit the way there is
no background to it that you would
expect to see them practicing learning
architectural skills the oldest
stuff should be the worst and as they
carry on it gets better that site ran
for a thousand years the best stuff is
the oldest a thousand years later what
they were producing wasn't so good this
is a real anomaly and it needs to be
investigated not mocked by skeptics but
actually explored to consider maybe this
does Rock the whole paradigm and it's
kind of ironic that in their desire to
get away from the ancient myths and
tales in the Bible they've ignored those
ancient myths and tales which all talk
about cataclysms well part of our modern
psychology is to imagine that we are
somehow so far advanced from our
predecessors that we now represent the
pinnacle of civilization and anything
that preceded us has to be looked upon
almost as you know as if the workings of
children it requires a major
psychological shift to admit or accept
that our ancestors have may have been
far far more sophisticated than than we
had imagined in our 19th century models
which basically still dominate thinking
today and you know in Graham's book he
devotes several chapters to the story of
one 19th 20th century heretic J Harlen
Bretz in his story to me kind of
encapsulates the whole the whole process
of forcing his paradigm shift and for
years he was out there exploring this
evidence that there had been this
tremendous flooding in Washington State
and all of his critics were dismissive
without ever even going out and looking
at the evidence firsthand in the field
but what he did was he stuck to his guns
for three decades and continued to amass
evidence to the point where they just
couldn't they couldn't dismiss it
anymore and finally a group of them went
out and began to explore the the
landscapes for themselves and one of the
leaders I think you talked about it in
your book James Gillooly who was sort of
the leader of the the skeptic faction
that had set out their sole purpose was
to discredit and lay this whole flood
heresy to rest once and for all but he
went out in the field and they spent
about eight days in the field where he's
seeing this evidence for himself over
and over again
and when you look at just one piece of
it you might be able to say okay there's
other explanations for that but what
happens is when you get multiple lines
of evidence all converging and there's
no way to individually explain away each
one of those things other than just
saying oh well it's all coincidence what
he this James Gillooly was honest enough
so that after a week out there they were
in a place called Palouse Falls in
southern Washington which was one of
these areas where these tremendous
inland tsunami swept across the land and
I actually just visited there about
eight weeks ago when I took a group of
people out there and and took them to
Palouse Falls to show them right on the
spot where James Gillooly was standing
when he finally had his epiphany divyam
images that that you brought with us I
have images I can dig them up here yeah
I sure do yeah I've got some really
interesting images to show you which
relates because see this flooding stuff
relates directly to the idea of the
impact and we can get into a little bit
of that explaining how how these
parallel lines of evidence are now
converging but the interesting thing
about but Gillooly was that in the India
descriptions of the trip he wandered off
by himself for a long time away from the
group and was standing here looking at
this massive cataract with 400 foot
cliffs in this little tiny ribbon of
water flowing over it in this huge
canyon below it and these big boulders
and he had seen for a whole week he'd
been seeing this stuff and it finally
got to the point where it wasn't
undeniable and he walked back to the
group and the words out of his mouth
verbatim were how could I have been so
wrong and he finally admitted and at
that that was like a turning point and
now and again Graham describes it's very
effectively in the book how in a way the
flooding phenomena was hijacked and then
placed within this more gradual istic
context to really to avoid the fact that
it was something so anomalous in so such
a departure from our modern experience
that we had to look outside of our
modern experience to find an explanation
what they wanted to do was find
something within our modern experience
and this is the the cornerstone of the
uniformitarian approach is that we look
for a modern example and then we
extrapolate backwards from that and so
what they did was they saw well in the
modern term in the modern world we have
Pro glacial lakes lake that's that form
in front of glaciers and sometimes these
Progreso Lakes might be held in by a ice
dam or another glacier these ice dams
will give away and they will cause
pretty catastrophic flooding they're
very common up in Iceland because you've
got several volcanoes under the law the
Icelandic ice sheets and up there they
use the term yokel ops to describe these
outburst floods but here's the thing
when you look at the modern versions of
it you basically are looking at floods
that are less than one thousandth of one
single flow from these floods we're
talking about that happened you know
twelve and thirteen thousand years ago
one thousand less than a thousand less
than a thousandth in peak discharge and
in total volume and and so it has been
admitted in several places I've
extracted the quote saying well we do
admit that this is a major extrapolation
upwards but never mind yeah you know was
it never mind is so disturbing me see
Holland breaths for 30 years was walking
the walk in the channeled scablands and
what he saw was evidence for as he
called it a humungous flood which which
actually Rosenthal within fell within
three weeks and and he went through
decades of being put aside by his
colleagues insulted they mocked him they
laughed at him just as the sceptics do
today but gradually the evidence began
to mount and they couldn't deny it any
more that there had been there had been
flooding and actually eventually they
gave Harlen Bretz Joe Holland Brett's
the Penrose medal which is the ultimate
you know the ultimate be stole of
geology in America he got the accolade
and he said at that he was aboard more
than 90 years old at that time and he
said at that time he said all my enemies
are dead so I have no one left to gloat
over but but the point is in a way there
was nothing to gloat about because what
they did was they they they
separated him from his central idea
instead of accepting that there had been
one huge flood and that was always his
view they said oh there must have been
70 or 80 floods that caused all this
damage and that's what we're that's what
we are seriously challenging right now
it's so ironic in a way that the human
desire for knowledge is what has led us
to where we are today we have this
insatiable desire for knowledge and for
innovation but that same human desire to
achieve is also what what's the the ego
is responsible for that
and the ego blocks anything that's
contrary to what you've already
established as fact exactly as soon as
you see something that might throw a
monkey wrench into the gears of what
you've been teaching and practicing your
whole life and I know that you've gone
through this with Egypt your your whole
issue with the Sphinx and with dr.
Schaack and John Anthony West was on the
podcast I was with you just recently
yeah he's amazing
by the way I'm going to be doing an
event in New York with John Anthony West
when on the 29th of November where it's
well it's in it again it's linked on my
website the details are on the talks and
events pages in its in some church
somewhere but I'm going to give a
presentation and then I'm going to
interview John live on live on stage
first time I've ever done that I'm kind
of podcasting you know in such a
character he's an amazing I love that
dude and in magical Egypt is I think one
of most important things anybody could
ever watch I think that DVD series is
just insane it's so spectacular and so
fantastic and next to going to Egypt
with that which I haven't done I think
that's probably the second best thing
just bet you back and John is an example
of why we need heretics this is this is
the thing you see that the science today
yes you're right we have this thirst for
knowledge and its case human
characteristic but also we get invested
in particular positions that when people
criticize those positions we take it as
an existential threat and where we beget
all angry and hot and bothered about it
if we allow that to happen too much we
don't keep a place for heretics in our
society then we're never going to do
anything novel we're gradually going to
get locked down ossified into the into
the existing system we need heretics
John has been the leading heretic on
ancient Egypt for decades pointing out
that we should listen to what the
ancient Egyptians said that their
civilization was not a divot
it was a legacy it was a legacy from the
time of the gods and that cast me back
again to this whole issue of a lost
civilization
now when gobekli tepe was discovered it
vindicated you in so many ways but what
are the possibilities if any of more of
these sites being explored and exposed
Amu's are there are there more that
people are looking at right now are
there any that are under the radar just
a year ago at the bottom of the Sicily
channel at a depth of more than a
hundred and twenty feet it's been
underwater for at least 9,000 years is a
huge megalithic site before the
discovery of Gobekli Tepe that site
could never have been explained the
dating is absolutely definite the Seas
rose and covered it at least 9,000 years
ago we don't know how long it stood
there before it was covered by the
rising seas but there it sits underwater
and I think underwater discoveries are
and I've had a part to play in this over
the years are one of the ways forward we
need to look at those areas because
there was a 400 foot rise in sea level
at the end of the Ice Age you're looking
at the amount of land that would be put
together in say Europe and China added
together that amount of land was
swallowed by those rising seas and
archaeology has largely proceeded
without taking account of those lost
lands I'm not saying they haven't looked
at all but they're primarily in marine
archaeology interested in shipwrecks now
this this megalithic site is there
images of this so we could look at there
are yeah yeah yeah I can I can probably
find it monolith at the bottom of the
Sicily channel try that try that a
search on that pull that up Jamie yeah
but so what does this look like is this
and is this been clearly established
that this actually is the work of man
this is not some sort of a yardang or
something of course there's dispute
right of course but the mainstream is
not going to just accept this overnight
but again it's mainstream scientists
have found it they're absolutely certain
that they're dealing with a man-made
site there are holes drilled through
these megaliths one of them is very very
large there's a series of other
megaliths around about it's not a
natural thing so here we're looking at
some of it right yeah so there's that
big big megalith broken into two parts
right there oh wow yeah and and and this
we can say a
often with archaeological sites the
problem is dating them you know for
example there are incredible megalithic
temples all over the island of Malta not
far away from this place incredible
megalithic temples but they can't date
the stone directly they have to date
organic material associated with the
stone and that can give them
misleadingly young dates in a case of a
site that's been covered by sea level
rise there can be no argument nobody
went down there and built that 9,000
years ago it had to be built before the
Seas rose and that puts a minimum age on
it of 9,000 years what are the best
images that we can look at because right
now I'm just seeing rocks it's very
difficult because I'm looking at so
that's I mentioned I'm afraid that's all
you're going to see those are those are
the best images of it that existed over
1 right above that that's in Yonaguni
okay that's not in that's not in the
Sicily channel so um what what are the
biggest pieces down there is it this
right here is this way yeah that big
thing big thing there I'm 30 feet long I
think and is it what what leads you to
believe that this is man-made the
scientists who worked on it the fact
that there are holes drilled through the
stone the fact that you can go to
neighbouring areas like Armenia and find
really very ancient megalithic sites
where they have exactly the same kind of
holes drilled through the stones and the
holes seem to have been used for
astronomical sightings now this sites a
mess it's been knocked over by the sea
it's fallen down but we're seeing the
same thing big megaliths with holes
drilled through them and you're also
dealing with 9,000 plus years of erosion
and barnacle arose all of it all of that
and the ocean is a difficult place to
work you know yeah it's it's it's not
easy visibility can be bad you're
dealing with currents there's all kinds
of all kinds of problems this is Britain
just cups Cameron this crazy little
submarine ring in James Cameron well I
spent seven years scuba diving or around
the world looking at this stuff and you
know it's pretty convincing in my view
well it is it does make sense that if we
do know for a fact and we do that the
sea level rose dramatically at the end
of the Ice Age it makes sense that some
things would be buried under the water
well in during the Ice Age whatever you
know you don't have to talk about
advanced civilizations or anything but
the during the Ice Age living on the
coastlines in establishing your
as communities everything on the
coastlines would have been probably one
of the most benign places to get you
know because for one thing you're down
near see the sea level this presence of
the Seas is going to you know smooth out
the climate and so forth so you know
you're going to have probably most
cultural development during the Ice Age
is going to be close to this to the sea
so it's going to be underwater now just
like Graham was talking about and so
this to me is probably the future of
archaeology as marine archaeology where
a lot of discoveries are going to be
made and in that particular thing I mean
there's a lot of megalithic structures
around the world that if you set that
thing up like this and put those citing
holes through it would look precisely
like scrape the barnacles off of it you
know and no one's saying oh it's proven
but what it is is we have to keep an
open mind and say well there are some
very strong similarities here so let's
investigate this thing further and
that's the whole point of all this is
all of this stuff needs more research it
doesn't need some Cavalier dismissal by
somebody who's you know protecting their
their own paradigm it needs more
research on all fronts I mean because I
think that there's enough evidence it is
now accumulated to suggest that there is
a deep history to the human species on
earth and we're just beginning to really
appreciate how much deeper really is
than the conventional models of history
and rather than just waving an arm and
dismissing this with a skeptical snare
with a skeptical sneer exactly oh it's
interesting is there's accepted
scientific models of humanity when
you're talking about supervolcano's
right like the super volcano of 60 70
thousand years ago towba yeah I mean
they're they pretty much accept that
wiped out of the vast majority of human
beings on earth mm-hmm and why is the
supervolcano hypothesis so easily
accepted but yet the asteroid impact
both of them are real events both of
them are historically documented in fact
we really don't we've never watched a
supervolcano take over the world but
we've seen asteroids hit other planets
we've actually watched shoemaker-levy
like you were talking about before we
call embodying Jupiter unbel
lievable bigger impact and the planet
Earth itself yeah yeah yeah exactly
exactly so yeah and actually more than
20 impacts each each each one of them
would have wiped out all life on Earth
if that if that object had hit the earth
yeah so you know so it's a it's a it's
very another thing too we were talking
about underwater structures but let's
also consider the possibility and again
john anthony west work is important here
let's also consider the possibility that
we have misidentified a number of
structures that are standing in plain
view like the great sphinx Egyptology
read any egypt logical text any
encyclopedia actually they will tell you
that thing was put there by a specific
Pharaoh Pharaoh Khafre of the fourth
dynasty round about 2500 BC that is not
a fact that is an opinion but it's
presented as a fact there is not a
single inscription that relates the
Sphinx to that fair or not a
contemporary experience Krypton not one
dating from 2500 BC in fact there's
nothing at all it's just the assumption
because it's close to a pyramid which
they assume the same pharaoh built again
on the absence of evidence that the
sphinx must have been built by them but
john anthony worse was the first to see
that actually when we look at the sphinx
we're looking at a highly eroded stone
object and that erosion is very odd and
that's why he brought professor Robert
Schoch professor of geology from Boston
University to Giza in 1992 to look at
the Sphinx and say what actually caused
this weathering on the Sphinx and shock
immediately saw it what caused it was
exposure to a very long period of heavy
heavy heavy rainfall and no such rains
have fallen in Egypt in the last five
thousand years but they did fall during
the Younger Dryas we had a prolonged
rain out from this comet impact as that
ice cap was pulverized and a massive
amount of ice water was thrown up into
the upper atmosphere prolonged rain ow
which could have been the cause of the
erosion on the Sphinx now what has
occurred new what discoveries have been
discovered in the last year like what
what is new that we can look at there in
terms of archaeology there's not much
new gobekli tepe
at the moment is in deep freeze it's
right 30 miles
from the Syrian border there's been
massive an unrest and unrest in
Chandelure which is that the main town
archeology is very difficult for them to
to carry on there it's basically just
frozen where it just sort of stopped
they've just kind of stopped you know
and in fact there's amazing number of
these of these sites another site I
visited from magicians of the girls was
bar back in the Lebanon absolutely
stunning site and again I'm convinced
that that site is nuanced it is yes
there is a Roman temple there but they
put that temple there because the site
was sacred long before and there's this
incredible u-shaped megalithic wall
which surrounds Baalbek which does not
appear to have any connection to the to
the Roman structure at all again that's
an area which is subject to tremendous
unrest and difficulty and it's difficult
for archaeologists to proceed but just
just in 2014 they they made a huge new
discovery at Baalbek of a buried block
which weighs one thousand four hundred
and sixty tons which was sitting there
on the site that they'd been working
that site for a hundred years they only
found it in 2014 Wow 1000 tonnes 1462 is
that two million pounds so that is like
I don't know it may be what math is
better than mine and converting it into
pole one times 2,000 pounds yeah 2,000
pounds to her to a turn to an imperial
ton so whatever and I had three zeros on
it double it and had 3 zeros on it it's
a horrendous amount of pounds to put
that way this it's a single largest
block of stone ever cut and quarried in
the ancient world and they found this
just in 2014 found it in 2014 now
there's another big one right beside it
which has been in plain view for about
the last hundred years and it's
astonishing to me that this one which is
just below it was covered by sediment
that we have a national calculator you
might be the only person unless I never
go anywhere without my calculator uh-huh
nobody has one of those we were just
talking about that yesterday you're like
who the [ __ ] assistant is an actual car
I'm the last guy take care of you when
it while the so Baalbek was also the
site of I mean there's many mountain
monoliths that have been discovered
there and it's really fascinating site
that most any people have sort of
overlooked
when you talk about ancient structures
absolutely I have to resist I I've got
nothing against aliens but I don't need
aliens to explain these things I I think
a much a much leaner and more elegant
explanation for these huge
archaeological anomalies is a lost human
civilization much better it has been the
case that I've been making for 25 years
I think the the alien thing is a bit of
a distraction but of course there's
aliens of course the universe is full of
life but the ancient archaeological
sites are not good evidence for that
idea that they're very unless you
massage the evidence a lot they're not
good evidence I think we are dealing
with a lost human civilization and at
Baalbek 20 feet above the ground we have
three blocks of stone join so closely
together that you can't get it edge of a
sheet of paper between them each one
weighs more than 900 tons and they are
20 feet above the ground it's a stun
it's a stunning achievement it's just
absolutely astonishing how on earth did
they do and how does mainstream
archaeology deal with that they say are
the Romans built it all are the Romans
yeah the Romans did it the Romans did do
some awesome stuff they did do some
awesome stuff they absolutely did but
this site is separate from the Roman
site it surrounds it but it's not part
of it in my view in terms of your
question what's happened within the last
year or two I would think that probably
the most significant thing or certainly
right up there would be the the comet
research and the discovery I mean like
this article I have right here which
came out in 2014 so it's not that old a
nano diamond-rich
layer across three continents consistent
with major cosmic impact at twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago and
it's something like 2425 highly
pedigreed scientists and these are the
comet research group gives scientists
from the comet research group who have
funded all their research themselves
they came out with another paper in 2050
where was this published if anybody
wants to read this that's in the Journal
of geology yeah but then there's the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences hosts a lot of their work as
well and the Proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences get into trouble for
hosting their work but they feel it's
important so they keep on hosting it
this is so spectacularly confusing to me
because that's rocks
science yeah this is evidence it
actually can weigh this stuff you can
measure it you can you could run tests
on it and find out what its components
are this to me is so baffling yeah it's
very baffling they had brought out
another paper in 2015 I won't go into
the some of the details are boring but
it's called a Basie and chronological
analysis and basically what they're what
they were looking at is it they asked
themselves is it possible that this
evidence these nano diamonds these melt
glass the Carbon spherules could that
have been laid down gradually and the
chronological analysis that they've done
absolutely answers that no it was not
laid down gradually this whole thing
unfolded in a period of about 24 hours
whoa what a night yeah in what had
happened Joe was that for years
archaeologists had recognized this up
Ede black matte layer at about two dozen
or more of the Clovis sites around North
America which there had been over 50 of
them that have been studied and it was C
Vance Haines who wrote an interesting
paper saying that he was the one who
noted that below this black matte layer
which is only two to three inches thick
in most sites you found evidence of the
Clovis culture you found their toolkits
and their their spear points and so on
you found evidence of the extinct
megafauna but not above it you would
find this evidence of this cultural
activity and the megafauna right up to
the bottom of the of the black mat layer
but not above it so what finally
happened was in 2007
Richard Firestone and Alan West and some
of their colleagues and it was just
basically a small group at that point
took a look at this closer look and
that's when they began to discover these
impact proxies usually right at the base
of the layer and the layer itself is
carbonaceous which suggests that there
had been a lot of soot deposited which
would imply widespread wildfires factors
to study off the red off the coast of
California on the Santa Rosa Islands
that pretty much concluded that there
was just massive wildfires that pretty
much just annihilated everything
and then this was preceded by the
deposition of this black matte layer and
right at the bottom of this black matte
layer is where you'll find the nano
diamonds the magnetic grains the
microspheres the carbonaceous Ferrell's
fullerenes you find these impact proxies
and they're not all the same at all the
sites in fact that's been one of the
things that the critics have seized upon
but what they're doing is I think taking
an oversimplified model and when you
look at a comet fragmentation event you
could be looking at the individual
pieces could be have very different
compositions and what we were talking
about earlier the torrid meteor stream
I'm not convinced at this point it was
necessarily just a single impact event
it may have been a bombardment episode
that may have lasted even several
decades it may have then ceased for a
while and we were talking about this
last night over dinner that there seems
to be a second spasm at eleven thousand
six hundred years ago that's also
associated with a massive rise in sea
level they call there's two meltwater
spikes meltwater spike one a in
meltwater spike one B I'm quite
convinced that these meltwater spikes
that have been documented by marine
geologist and oceanographers are
correlated with these melting events of
the ice sheet that I've been looking at
in terms of their their geomorphic
consequences because some of these
events I mean the only way I can
describe some of these meltwater events
is that you the only modern analog to
this would be a tsunami and we've seen
some pretty devastating tsunamis within
the last decade or two both in Indonesia
and in Japan and I don't know if you've
ever seen any of like the videos of
these tsunamis anybody listening it is
definitely worthwhile to go online and
look at some of these videos where you
can actually see the the unbelievably
powerful effects of a 30 or 40 or 50
foot tsunami right now some of the
landscapes and I have a some images we
can pull up here shortly are places in
Montana Idaho Washington where you
literally had a tsunami sweeping over
the land there was over a thousand feet
deep and that tsunami came off the
I'm not an oceanic tsunami that's like
it's a freshwater tsunami
it's meltwater coming off this this
catastrophic melting of the ice sheet
and I've traced the sources of some of
these meltwater I've made two trips now
up into the into the plateau country of
British Columbia looking for the source
of this meltwater because in the
conventional models now of this this
flooding this that goes back to Harland
breaths and basically what they've done
is they said initially there could have
been no flood because Harlen Bretz
didn't provide a source for the water
they said the critic said well you're
saying that all of this evidence in the
landscape is evidence of the flood but
what was the source of the flood and he
didn't have a source so the critics then
said well you don't have a source for
the flood water therefore the flood
didn't take place then as as the
research evolved you had independent
evidence accumulating in western Montana
by JT Pardee who was with the US
Geological Survey and he was
investigating evidence that the mountain
valleys of western Montana had been
filled up with an enormous volume of
water and this volume of water seemed to
be exactly the same time as brett's as
floods he then assumed that this was a
giant lake and because you can see and
we can I think we have some images I
think Jamie has some images so we'll
pull him up shortly we're on the
mountain side you see the shorelines
itched you know a thousand feet above
the valley floor and what he then
decided was that based upon an old
nineteenth-century interpretation by TC
Chamberland that there had been an ice
dam he said well there must have been an
ice dam west of here somewhere in the
Clark Fork Valley a giant lake backed up
burst through the ice dam and then this
is what would have caused Harlen Bretz
'as floods so now the geological
community is shifting because number one
the evidence is overwhelming and they
can't deny it anymore but what they're
doing is looking for a gradualist or a
more uniformitarian explanation so they
immediately latched on to this well
there's a giant Pro glacial or in front
of a glacial lake in western Montana
well you're talking about somewhere
between
five hundred and twenty and five hundred
and fifty cubic miles of water that's a
lot of water right in in and normally
when you have a large lake you have a
huge catchment base and it is feeding
lots of streams and rivers that are
feeding into that lake when you look at
the any of the big lakes around North
America you have the lake and then you
have this big old catchment basin and
all of that's feeding in Lake Missoula
the whole lake fills almost the whole
catchment basin it's like to me what
they did was they said okay we're just
going to push the source of the water
from here over to here but let's not go
into the question of where did the water
come from that's filling these mountain
valleys of western Montana and this is
what I spent a couple of weeks in
September going up into some of these
following these valleys up into British
Columbia and there's spectacular
evidence and it's almost like the
American geologist stopped at the 49th
parallel and they say well that's the
Canadians preserve up there
we'll let them they've got their own
theories we've got ours interestingly
the Canadians are saying that we think
that the water for these floods came
from up here but they don't like that
because you see one of the leading
geologists who was saying that these
floods came from from Canada is John
Shaw who who basically came up there was
idea that drumlins which are these
inverted boat hull shaped landforms that
are found by hundreds of thousands in
regions where where glaciers were that
they were formed not by the glaciers
grinding over the landscape but they
were actually formed by massive sub
glacial flows of water and his critics
have all been saying well here's the
problem what's the source of your water
therefore it wasn't water wasn't sub
glacial floods is easy parallels the
Harlen Bretz a story very closely well
here's the thing
Shaw and his colleagues couldn't really
come up with a plausible explanation for
how you could form these massive sub
glacial reservoirs in fact what they
call the Livingstone Lake event required
eighty four thousand cubic kilometers of
water
and I eighty-four thousand kilometers I
can do it really quickly here we divide
that by 36
that's about 2300 cubic miles of water
that's more than all of the great lakes
combined vastly bigger than all of the
Great Lakes combined it's probably every
Lake in North America combined and he
said this one event required over two
thousand cubic miles of water well where
did that water come from
so he basically said well there must
have been a reservoir somehow that
formed his critics have said that's
impossible you couldn't form that much
water under the ice sheet well what's
happened now is the idea of a major
cosmic impact into the ice sheet has
completely obviated the need for a sub
glacial reservoir because now we have a
way of instantaneously melting enormous
volumes of ice it's no longer a mystery
when the water came from fully explained
and this has been the missing piece of
the puzzle until the comet research
group began to identify this evidence
well it's baffling to me that this is a
source of controversy because we know
that the Great Lakes were created by
melting glaciers we also know that
there's vast areas of North America that
are flattened by these glaciers you know
a buddy mine my friend Doug lives in
Cazenovia Wisconsin which is what's
called the Driftless area where the
glaciers didn't go through I just was
there in May it's peuta a it's beautiful
it's gorgeous give rolling hills and
it's just it wasn't it wasn't crushed
flat like other parts of North America
were right so we know we know that those
glaciers melted and they created the
Great Lakes I mean the Great Lakes were
from glaciers we know that that's an
established fact so why is all this
confusing I just don't understand why
they wouldn't just add that to it they
just can accept the great glaciers
somehow or another in the last 10,000
years
the glaciers just decided to stop
smashing North America flat and melt and
create these great inland oceans of
fresh water yeah yeah those are it's
it's very bizarre ultimately a lot of
ideology is is involved in this there's
there's that there's this desire also in
the modern world there's a desire not to
panic the public not to say things that
are that are going to cause that are
going to cause panic you
now with Donald Trump being president I
think people ready now I think people
are ready for panic I think so has
anybody debated you on this either one
of you on this well you know I tried to
Dan but not specifically on this I tried
to do a debate with Zahi Hawass who was
the guy who runs the Giza pyramids and
the madman yeah yeah total total I mean
very crazy event there's a video of it
online there's a video video of it
online the debate last what 30 second is
something like something like that yeah
yeah yeah and then and then later on
when he when he finally agreed to come
back into the room because he was so
angry with me walked out when he finally
came back into the room he was asked a
question about gobekli tepe and just
like you're skeptic he didn't know
anything about gobekli tepe or he
claimed not to know about I mean this is
that this is supposed to be the world's
most famous archaeologist and he knew
nothing about this incredible site in a
weenie in a neighboring country but one
point to make the Randall was talking
about the second event eleven thousand
six hundred years ago we're dealing with
an with with an episode of Cataclysm
begins twelve thousand eight hundred
years ago and ends eleven thousand six
hundred years ago both episodes
accompanied by massive floods and the
eleven thousand six hundred years ago
date I may have mentioned this last year
it's in it's in magicians of the gods
what's interesting about that is that is
the exact date that Plato gives us for
the destruction of the lost civilization
of Atlantis
Plato that's the only source we have for
Atlantis it comes to us many people
think it's all over the place but it's
not
Atlantis comes to us from the Greek
philosopher Plato who lived around 340
BC and he got the story from through his
family line from his ancestor Solon who
had visited Egypt in 600 BC and there
Solon was told of a great civilization
that had existed on earth that was the
progenitor civilization of Egypt but
that was destroyed in a terrible
Cataclysm and he asked are there
Cataclysm involving a gigantic flood and
Atlantis was submerged beneath the waves
and was never seen again and so Solon
said to the priests when did this happen
and they said three to nine thousand
years ago that was in 600 BC so that's
9600 BC that's eleven thousand six
hundred years ago that's melt water
pulse 1b how could they know
yeah how could we have to start taking
this stuff more seriously instead of
sneering at it and skepta sizing it out
of existence we need to leave a little
bit of room for extraordinary ideas
possibly being right that's the main
beef I have with the skeptics is that
they want to throw the baby out with the
bathwater I want to add something to
that in the Timaeus
you know Plato discusses Atlantis in two
dialogues and in two Timaeus he preface
'as the story of Atlantis by recounting
the myth of Phaeton now the myth of
Phaeton is a very interesting story and
basically what it is as Phaeton was the
offspring of hey Leo's the Sun God who
was raised didn't know who his father
was
his mother kept it a secret from him and
then one day he was being taunted at
school because all of his schoolmates
had you know recounting the great deeds
of their fathers and everything so he
went home distraught and finally his
mother said well actually your father is
the the big granddaddy of them all
Helios the Sun God so Phaeton decides
he's going to go and find his father and
eventually does and he goes to some you
know celestial realm or his father is
located and the way it is with the with
it with the Greek gods they have
unlimited powers except they also have
certain restrictions for example if a
God makes a promise he or she cannot go
back on it right so when hey Leo sees
Phaeton has his lost son come he's
overjoyed he says I'm so happy to see
you I will grant you any boon you want
and Phaeton says i want to drive the
chariot to the Sun I want to drive your
chariot and hey Leo says well I meant
anything you wanted except that you know
so it goes back and forth and back and
forth finally fate and convinces his
father let him let me do it his father
says look you've got to hang onto those
reins tight because those steeds are
going to pull away from you he gets in
there the gates of the Sun open it
describes in the myth you can go you
know you can read Edith Hamilton or
Bulfinch or any of the great retellings
of the Greek myths and they'll describe
it in there it goes through the signs of
the zodiac and then all of a sudden it
careens off and heads down to earth and
then it describes this whole litany of
catastrophe
setting the earth on fire and finally
the Jupiter at the the the beseeching of
Poseidon who is afraid that the oceans
are going to boil away get Zeus to mount
his his Mount Olympus and hurl his
Thunderbolt which knocks Phaeton from
the sky and he falls to earth and falls
into the river air adonis which is a
metaphor for the Milky Way and his
sisters the hell yachties then weep over
the death of their brother and their
tears fall to earth and cause the great
flood
Plato then after referencing that myth
he then says now this has the form of a
myth but what it really represents is a
declination or a declining of the bodies
in space orbiting around the earth in an
eventual falling to earth of one of
those bodies and a conflagration of all
things triggered by the fall of that
body it's intriguing that he mentions
the zodiac because because the torrid
meteor stream is so cold because it
appears to come at us from the direction
of the constellation of Taurus the
zodiacal constellation that's where
those shooting stars amongst which are
some very large objects that that have
hit us in the past and can hit us again
in the future that's where they come
from they come from that area of the sky
it's an actually an illusion it appears
that they're not actually coming from
Taurus it looks like that they come from
that area of the sky they come from that
area of the sky and so anybody in in
ancient times who was witnessing and
according to the Victor Clube and
William Napier and those guys who are
the British neo catastrophists that have
been doing all of this work for decades
on the toward meteor shower have
concluded that you know in times past it
was an extremely active shower and would
have created some pretty darn impressive
light shows even if it wasn't causing
catastrophes down here below but what
they've what they've conjectured is that
there might be times of multiple
Tunguska like impact bombardment when
you know there could because there could
be thousands of objects within the tarde
meteor stream on the same scale as the
Tunguska object and that if if you go
and you read the accounts the eyewitness
accounts over and over
and people are saying things like well
it looked like it was being discouraged
from the Sun it looked like it was being
born out of the Sun right it looked like
a second Sun in the sky like for a short
period of time the Sun had a twin right
well the summertime torrents are coming
from their parody lien passage around
the Sun so you like grain was saying
they make an elliptical orbit out to
Jupiter and back around the Sun in this
stream right earth crosses that stream
twice each year one time late June early
July we cross but at that point they're
coming from the direction of the Sun so
their their arrival to earth is going to
be very difficult to see because they're
coming from the direction of the Sun
right but that's exactly where on June
30th a torrid meteor would be coming
from and then also the fact that it's
that the perfect date for the peak of
the of the shower and the correct place
in the sky to me is pretty convincing
evidence that it was most likely a
remnant of that torrid stream the other
time that the earth crosses is late
October early November in fact we've
just passed out of it within the last
week basically but it Peaks
interestingly coincidentally between
like October 30th and November 4th or
5th so it's peaking right around
Halloween time in fact they've been
called the Halloween meteors and there's
some very intense I work sometimes thing
called the Halloween fireworks yeah but
there's some very interesting work done
by a researcher back around the early
20th century named grant Halliburton who
spent about 15 years researching the
connections between ancient calendars
and he concluded one thing very
interesting was that a lot of these
ancient calendars were being
synchronized by people's observations of
the rise and fall of the Pleiades which
is the shoulder of the bull the Pleiades
comprises basically part of that
constellations like Taurus yeah yeah the
shoulder of the bull and what he came up
with was that in his research he
discovered that many of these stories
that were associated with us like the
slaying of the celestial bull you know
Gilgamesh and Enkidu in the in the
earliest
known story they they fight the
celestial boulders many counterparts and
variants of that in mythical stories and
so what he then found out though was
that in many cases the that our modern
Halloween actually goes back thousands
of years to an ancient day of the Dead
that was observed all over the earth at
the same time every year even in the
southern hemisphere and it usually
revolved around a commemoration of the
the culmination of the Pleiades which is
when the Pleiades crosses the local
Meridian in other words it reaches the
keystone of the Royal Arch so to speak
up in the sky so if you go out on
Halloween now and you face the south in
the northern hemisphere you will see the
Pleiades right at midnight at midnight
they will be if you think of the the
arch of the zodiac as being a like a
clock it's right there at midnight at
midnight right well here's the
interesting link is that in all of these
myths
what halliburton discovered over and
over again was that the Day of the Dead
ultimately went back to myths about of
the destruction of the world by a great
flood and/or fire it's fascinating that
it's all coming out of the constellation
Taurus - and it's the celestial bull
that they're fighting in these ancient
myths and then all these cultures around
the worlds are celebrating the day of
the dead of this exact same time this
amazing stuff and right now our science
is closing its eyes to this I I think
it's fair to say with the torrid meteor
stream which is a very big issue in this
whole discussion that we are dealing
with a hidden hand in human history it's
something that is going to ultimately
require us to re-explain almost
everything that the skeptics hate it
they can't bear it because first of all
it involves cataclysms and secondly it
involves the possibility of losing a
whole civilization from the record it's
really it's really interesting when you
look at the dates of the this cluster
this episode of bombardment between
twelve thousand eight hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred years ago that's
the period that just immediately
precedes what mainstream academia think
of as the very beginnings of
civilization and they've just never
maybe if not even their fault it's this
is so recent this science is so new that
they've not had time to adapt to it but
if they adapt to it and take this into
account then suddenly what was an
extraordinary and absurd an impossible
idea that there was a lost civilization
twelve thousand years ago
becomes a very plausible and reasonable
idea and then we start once we can once
we take that on board then we can start
opening our eyes to archaeological
anomalies like the Great Sphinx like
Baalbek like submerged ruins like
gobekli tepe and begin to consider what
does all this mean are we in fact a
species with amnesia are we here
forgetful of the truth about ourselves
maybe that's why we're so [ __ ] up you
know because we just actually don't know
we've made up a story about where we
came from what we are I certainly think
it plays a part and I also think that
conservative skepticism is probably
prudent when you're dealing with most
scientific issues most things that come
up that people are claiming I mean
there's so many charlatans out there
crazy people that are claiming new
discoveries but uh in some cases they
examine these discoveries as long as
they're far enough away from us or weird
enough like this new planet that they
believe they're they have a 90 planet
sign in yeah yeah they they're pretty
sure there's something outside past the
Kuiper belt and they think it's massive
they think it's at least four times
maybe larger than the United States or
then excuse me the world down the world
and got an orbit of about ten thousand
years yeah and that's interesting with
comets because this huge massive object
circulating in the outer solar system
through the Kuiper belt which is the
source of many of the comets that hit
the earth is destabilizing comets from
safe orbits and putting them into really
dangerous orbits they come our way the
correctly from wrong but like what what
is the source of all these near-earth
objects do is this have anything to do
with earth one and earth two does it
have anything to do with the initial
impact that created the moon is that
because we were hit by another planet
right during the formation of the earth
and this is all scientifically
established Astro scientists or
astrophysicists rather and astronomers
all agree on that right there's a lot of
debris
would go back to that to that time and
but comets are another story because
they're coming in from the far reaches
of outer space they're coming they're
coming in from the Oort cloud and the
coital just vast distances away they're
their voyagers they're kind of messages
from the distant reaches of the cosmos
who come in in an unpredictable way
because their orbits are destabilized by
something like Planet nine isn't there
something called bodes law where you you
can measure the mass and the orbit of a
certain planet and you can accurately
depict where the next planet is going to
be and doesn't that fall apart somewhere
between Mars and Jupiter that's with the
asteroid belt yeah yeah yeah which would
indicate that something was probably
there what in the theory of the asteroid
belt that it was an exploded planet of
course there's a lot of opposition to
that theory too you know you're right
skepticism really has an important role
to play it's it's very it's really it's
really essential that we are skeptical
otherwise we'd all be following on
zecharia sitchin for the Anunnaki to
land exactly it would have sold our
houses December 21st 2012 we'd all be
going with the [ __ ] now I'm homeless
example years later I have to say
there's a skeptic called Michael Heizer
who has done really an excellent job of
thoroughly you know debunking the bogus
translations of zecharia sitchin is
wrong coms hitch in his wrong doctor
it's a very useful it's a very useful
site so we hated him and loved him at
the same time is so sad I love the idea
of the aliens come down and manipulating
the monkeys and making us to mine gold
it's a wonderful story but unfortunately
it's a work of science fiction it's not
a work of fact yeah we need I knew him
he was a fascinating man I once drove
him from Stonehenge to London we had we
had many conversations he was a deep and
serious researcher but I think he I
think he got he got carried away with
his own fence I also think that that
fantasy became very lucrative and it
also became a source of identity to him
yeah you know I followed him pretty
closely as well I've read the 12th
planet and I got really India's research
and this is in my early pot-smoking days
when I first started smoking pot so I
was I was all-in I was all-in and then
as I got wiser and then as I got not
honest maybe not wiser just I started
recognizing objectively why
these these things are so attractive the
fantastical is more attractive than the
practical and so something else again I
don't want I don't want to put Sitchin
down and I'm here also to say that
Sitchin did a lot of really good work
he's a clever guy and he had a lot of
very very very thorough research
I just lost my track actually smoking
too much dope where was I going what we
were talking about that all the
difference between the fantastical and
the practical that there's this
inclination to accept things that are
fun yeah you know that's what I was
going to say is that when you start
talking about the Anunnaki those from
heaven to earth cane these fantastic
creatures from thank you you've brought
my memoranda Bureau thing I remember I
was got to say what's interesting some
part because I know kind of once could
be good what was what's what's
interesting is that the level of
technology that Zakaria attributes to
the Annunaki oblique Nephilim that that
level of Technology is the level of
technology that we had in the 1970s when
we were you know NASA was doing its
stuff so it's NASA technology from the
1970s that is projected out on to that
is projected over a gram but is
projected out that is projected out on
to his theory of the past now it seems
to me very unlikely that the Nephilim or
the Anunnaki would have had for four
hundred thousand years which is what
he's saying the same technology that
NASA had in the 1970s is much more
likely that he's projecting that on to
the data rather than that it's actually
inherent in the dot there was also some
interesting ideas that he had that
turned out to be ideas that scientists
had also proposed about preserving our
atmosphere by by levitating or by
suspending reflective particles in our
atmosphere and that that is something
that the Annunaki in his books we're
going to use gold for because gold has
such unique properties which is why they
use gold to plate things because you can
take a little tiny piece of gold you
could plate this entire table goals are
really spectacular yeah a piece of I
mean there's nothing like it right
absolutely not there's a lot of really
good material in Szczecin but
unfortunately the translations of the
texts the translations of the texts are
not translations of
texe they misrepresent the text often
what he did was he took a
nineteenth-century translation and he
massaged it so that it would you know
fit his fit his argument and that's a
pity so we need skeptics and they help
us to sift out the wheat from the chaff
but but occasionally what the skeptics
do with this drive to to criticize
anything that's not mainstream
occasionally what they do is they let go
a really good idea which deserves
investigation and which the human
species could benefit from and that's my
feeling is with this amazing species
we've developed all this science why are
we why are we so ready to let go of
wonderful ideas well it's also
fascinating to me that because of what
Sitchin has been sort of criticized for
people now ignore the stuff that's
absolutely undeniable like the actual
stone tablets themselves the clay
tablets where you can see the depictions
of the solar system somehow or another
these people from 6,000 plus years ago
had a detailed map of the sources clear
idea of the source
what's the size in like a relatively
correct order in the planets in the
right place like they somehow or another
knew that Jupiter was bigger than Mars
they knew these things in some weird way
and we don't know why we don't know how
also the caduceus representing the the
the double helix of the DNA that's
really fascinating concept to that the
caduceus is used for medicine that's
used to reports that Gaia did
so it's kind of too bad there was so
much crazy involved in that I think what
any of us should do when we're exploring
the deep and hidden mysteries of the
past is is to go to a lot of different
sources go to a lot of don'ts just stick
with the mainstream don't just stick
with the alternative but try to try to
bring it all together and in a way
that's what I try to do in my books
accept the skeptics still hate them
yeah but it is so hard because it's so
it's so fun to go with the crazy story
yeah like the the alien story is so
compelling it's so fun very compelling
story I mean if we found some sort of
evidence of aliens it would be so
utterly spectacular even if it was a
simple alien like I've always said this
that if we felt like got a jellyfish on
the moon we would freak out
but you know there's really complex
bizarre things at the bottom of our
ocean that we've never discovered just
they're just not in the correct location
for us to be excited and then the other
the other issue we're getting slightly
off our flood topic here actually but
the other issue of entities that that in
the encounters with entities anybody
who's smoked DMT will know that as I
have as you have that will know that you
do encounter entities in the DMT in the
DMT state and they do communicate with
us and there's a lot of parallels with
the ETS or the aliens as they're
described in modern UFO abduction
accounts and Rick Strassman have you
ever had him on your show you know Rick
got sick he was supposed to be here a
couple of times we're trying to
reschedule it now yeah but he had some
pretty serious health issues now we had
a date scheduled out but I love that guy
got a chance to sit down with him a
couple of times and talk to him and of
course you presented DMT this molecule
yeah he's brilliant and he's so
important to me because I remember when
I did it I was so confused I mean it to
me it was like the first my first DMT
experience changed everything I thought
about the world and I immediately didn't
give a [ __ ] about aliens anymore right
like it was almost instantaneous like
before then I was like Roswell they've
got the they got the ship man yeah it's
in a hangar but what I encountered doing
DMT was so spectacularly alien it's a
pedestrian concept of something that
looks like a person but has a bigger
head enlarged eyes at high attack yeah
yeah it was weird and cool as it would
be if it was real it was nothing I mean
literally not one millionth as
interesting as what you absolutely can
encounter when you do DMT that's the
aliens that's the aliens that utterly
alien realm filled with alien
intelligences who communed and of course
again the skeptics say oh it's all just
made up in your brain but we don't know
that and Rick is open to the possibility
that we are dealing with areas of
reality that are not normally accessible
to our senses and that become accessible
to our senses by retuning the receiver
wavelength of the brain which is what he
suggests DMT does and I think I think
that's very plausible and at the very
least those who are interested in UFOs
and aliens should be also investigating
this line of inquiry can we can we use
changes in consciousness to understand
the majestic complexity of the universe
in which
we live and I think the answer is
definitely yes and many of Rick's
volunteers I paraphrase but they came
back with reports that the entities
who'd encountered them said we're so
glad you've discovered this technology
now we can communicate with you much
more easily you know it's fascinating so
there's a technology for encountering
other intelligences and against that
this mechanistic simplistic alien meme
that's going around now that they're a
bit like us but they came here in higher
tech the higher tech it's dull by
comparison with it is dull by comparison
if you're interested in anybody is the
book is amazing it's called DMT the
spirit molecule and he has a new book
that he's putting out about DMT and the
spirit and the soul of prophecy yeah and
he's just a really really interesting
guy but his his experience that he did
experiments that he did were the first I
think in many many decades to get
approved by the government correct so he
did everything above-ground I mean he
was above board he was did and because
it because it was government approved
the his remit was that he had to find
some therapeutic benefit for DMT and he
couldn't actually but that's not the
point
I'm sure actually there are therapeutic
benefits but that's not the point the
point is here is a tool for
investigating the mystery of
consciousness and the mysterious nature
of reality and I mean fact me if we get
five or six volunteers who haven't
compared notes or coming back with met
entities who said we're so happy you
found this technology yeah it's hard to
explain that as just to reduce it to
brain activity not only that when we
talk about things that are so big and
are ignored by mainstream culture this
is one that's just like that you're
talking about an endogenous human
chemical yeah that not only is in US but
is in thousands of different plants like
when how many different plants contain
DMT huge numbers huge very prosaic ones
like peas and you know well there's the
money recorder okay yeah that's what I
was gonna say the australian oriental
tree is actually illegal this isn't that
what would be the jerusalem the the
professors from the university of
jerusalem i believe that any shannon
yeah what they were talking about they
believe that that's what the story of
the burning bush and moses is so that is
Mimoza with the DMT and syrian rule with
the monoamine oxidase inhibitor in other
word
it's it's ayahuasca but a Middle Eastern
alternative of it doing the same thing
we like molecularly and isn't it
possible in some way that the idea of
the burning bush was them figuring out
how to dry or extract DMT never in it
very light very possibly right because
they're talking about the burning bush
producing God yeah and it just so
happens that this bush is the acacia
tree is incredibly common in super-rich
and DMT and it's all over the area and I
should probably insert at this point
that if you're at all familiar with the
Masonic ritual you'll know that the
acacia plant plays a central role that's
why you're one of them one percent Mason
characters every now every now it was
inside every now and then on face book
Randall I get accused of being a
freemason Hancock is a freemason as know
it explains as though it explains
everything I know lots of Freemasons I
spoken in Masonic lodges but I'm an
author and I shouldn't belong to clubs
you know I went to a few I went to a
wedding that my friend Duncan Trussell
was performing at for these two
Satanists and like 2003 into this day I
was the one of the lavas Anton LaVey or
Stanton Levay whatever is his son oh and
his son got married was some young
hedonist you know and they call
themselves Satanists and so Duncan
performed at this wedding and I went
there to this day
I get [ __ ] tweets about being a
Satanist so I can't join your little
club pal no one of your Masons I I need
to confess you Graham yes you didn't
realize this but I secretly initiated
you oh my god oh you're in so he get in
how do you self really initiate somebody
can you do that yeah no okay yes I sort
of did sort of so you could get him in
if you wanted to though right if you
know the people oh of course you even
you Joe I don't think something's gonna
happen bro I didn't I met a couple of
Masons they're very cool well most
masons don't really understand the
corpus of symbolism that's that they're
sitting on top of I got to say that not
to get off on the Freemasons but simply
there's a mass of symbolism and that's
the whole that's that's the thing that
they're custodians of and most of them
don't have a clue what it means but
they're doing an important job by
preserving this corpus of symbolism
through the through the layout of the
lodge
the the meaning of every component in
the lodge because it's a purely
astronomical allegory and then you have
the Masonic carpets and that's where you
have the whole story of the comet the
flood it's all there the acacia plant
it's all there it's all correct me for
my wrong but it's it's all also an
integral part of how Washington DC was
designed is that true yeah just so much
I haven't you know I honestly haven't
studied that okay but what I've seen is
that there's a there's a bunch of videos
where you can watch it where they sort
of describe how the layout you know is
in some way some sort of sacred geometry
I think what is based on Freemasons were
massively involved in the construction
of Washington as they were of many great
cities city I live in England has got
you know the major Masonic architecture
so is it like people like me like my
initial prejudice I hear something like
the Masons I got [ __ ] dudes in a cult
get out of here leave me alone like we
we assume that all groups of people that
follow anything somehow another wacky
Masons in my opinion they're largely a
drinking club for men mainly that's what
it is guys win at all but they do can
make special arrangements to bring women
into a lot of my life when I've get when
I've given a talk in a lodge I've given
talks in two or three lodges been asked
to do so then they make a special
ceremony to allow my wife Santa to come
in because I won't go anywhere without
Santa and so women can women can go in
but then there are more there are others
within masonry who are pursuing deeply
esoteric interest and exploring the
mysteries and you can have incredible
conversations and facet it's just
another another group of people who you
know are doing are doing their thing
it's not for me I wouldn't join I don't
I would lose I think if I joined
Freemasonry it would weaken me as an
author I think I think I'm better able
to comment on these things by not being
a member of any such group that's
interesting why do you think that well
because I think I have to remain open to
all possibilities and if I if I if I
commit myself to a particular line I
don't commit myself to a particular
religion I don't commit myself to a
particular men's club either I just
which is what masonry is I I think if I
commit that then a bit then ultimately I
would become a spokesperson for that and
I don't want to be that that makes a lot
of sense considering your occupation and
how important being open-minded has been
to your life it's vital
absolutely without it how could you have
ever done fingerprints of the guys I
could not you should have I mean and the
the thing the initial thing where you
were to tell me about Ethan that place
where they believe that the the Ark of
the Covenant lays which is one of the
most bizarre ideas ever and that was my
first book on a historical mystery with
the sign on the ceiling that's right and
when you go into it like it's so
interesting but I just I've always
imagined you as a young guy forced to
sort of reconcile with this bizarre
piece of evidence you've got these old
men that have cataracts in their eyes
like they're around radiation sites and
no one's allowed to go inside and see
this thing and they claim they have the
Ark of the Covenant in there and like
what the [ __ ] is in there I think was
the beginning of a magic it was the
beginning of a magical journey for me
it's been a magical journey for all your
fans too for guys like me man when I
read fingerprints of the gods it was to
me it was one of those books I just
couldn't put down and was so
mind-blowing and this is again was in my
the heart of my yeah fucking-a theorem
and fingerprints was published in 1995
and magicians came out in 20 in in 2015
and I would say in that time the the
evidence when I made the case for a lost
civilization and a global Cataclysm in
fingerprints of the gods I can't begin
to account for the amount of hostility
and anger and rage that I generated in
the academic community the idea was
considered to be absolutely absurd
twenty years later with magicians of the
gods
it's not so absurd anymore the evidence
is mounting we have incredible evidence
now for a global Cataclysm in exactly
the period that counts between twelve
thousand eight hundred eleven thousand
six hundred years ago and we have sites
like gobekli tepe we have a redefinition
of the Sphinx the whole area is just
about to explode in in the future we're
on the edge I believe of a paradigm
shift and this comet material is central
to it what I really appreciate about
your courage is that you've also had the
courage to admit when you've made
mistakes you're not you don't in any way
pretend to be some sort of a bearer of
secret knowledge no one else possesses
absolutely not a guru I don't want to be
anything like that I'm a reporter that's
that's what I am and I'm a reporter
who's reporting on offbeat subjects and
to some extent I'm an I'm an outsider so
one of the talks I do now
it's about being a being an outsider I
think there is a I think there is a
place for Outsiders in society well I
don't think you're an outsider I think
you're an outsider from the established
mainstream ideas I just think that is
what are the same we're both we're both
outsiders in that area I'm working in
different fields to get into this but
don't you think that these established
channels that were so deeply grooved in
distributing information those things
have widened so wide now what you're
getting I mean a professor could do a
podcast like he could teach a class you
could write a book or he can do a
podcast on a certain subject and like
you're aware of Dan Carlin and that
hardcore history podcast I just can't
stop raving about what he's done is
brought historical accurate but really
dramatic stories of real events that
took place to millions like you know
that's just that no one's doing that
like this is but it's not mainstream
well what's more mainstream than being
number one on the iTunes podcast list
which he is all the time what is more
mainstream and he must be getting
millions of downloads it's part of the
big change is taking place in our
society that the old structures are
being overthrown they're being thrown
away it's a very uncomfortable time it's
a very uncertain time is a very exciting
time right because we can build out if
there's something something amazing in
the future the Internet's had a huge
part to play in it the fact that people
can communicate with one another all
around the world since I've had a web
presence in the last I was late comer
but maybe 2 or 2 to 3 years ago I've
been getting contacted by I mean
professionals from around the world I've
got probably a dozen major ones I've
geologists who want to know more about
and interestingly you said earlier about
debating you know I'm always looking for
somebody to debate about that right I
you know because I have questions and
I'm thinking maybe somebody even
somebody who would disagree with me on
something good still help me answer some
of the questions right but I try to
associate as much as possible and hang
out with professionals in the field and
of course what I discover is that a lot
of them are working in these things
part-time almost clandestinely without
making it part of their you know if I go
on a field trip of geologists into the
flood lands none of them are really work
full-time it's all part-time you know
they're working for the government
they're working for the oil companies or
you know exploration mineral exploration
whatever they're doing this research
into geological catastrophes on their
own time right
but recently just last summer I got
invited to actually present some of my
research to the Atlanta Geological
Society which is the largest Society of
professional geologists in the southeast
so I jumped at the chance rather than
you know and so I presented hoping that
I would get challenged that somebody
would say wait a second there's a flaw
in your thinking you didn't happen so
did you make friends with some of these
mainstream geologists oh yeah well I
mean I've been known I mean I just took
a trip for um in September spent 10 10
days back out in the flood lines and I
did geologists with me on that trip so
yeah I'm getting to know more and more
people who are working as well you know
I I majored in geology and [ __ ] I still
am in touch regularly with the head of
the geology department I see her pretty
much on a regular basis and have been
keeping her apprised of some of my stuff
and she has off offered to sponsor me at
whatever point I think that I can pull
it together as a dissertation mm-hmm but
we'll see how that goes I mean my
objective was to learn geology not to
become a professional geologist that
wasn't interested in working for the
government or working for you know the
energy industry I had geological
questions and that's why I made in
geology and you've walked the walk and
in my opinion you know more about this
stuff than 10 fully PhD geologists yeah
you always freak me out so what's what's
fascinating to me about all this is that
I think what you've done has been very
measured you know everything you back up
with facts and photographs and
descriptions and disclaimers you know
when you when you say well it's it is
possible you will go down other various
paths you're not dogmatic about these
ideas but you've spent so much time
going over this I don't know if there's
another if there's a commensurate guy in
mainstream archaeology that has been
public about it the way you have been
because if there is I feel like we
probably would have heard about him your
podcasts have been the ones that we've
done they'd been seen by millions of
people they didn't listen to by millions
of people I mean the information is
getting out there and making a real
difference you're always going to have
the the guys like I think Michael
Shermer is very important and not
criticizing him but that knee-jerk
reaction to do something to mock
something or put down something that's
not mainstream like one of his tweets he
said you know what archaeology with
evidence is and he wrote archaeology
like why would you even tweet that this
doesn't make any sense like that someone
who's not paying attention to work but
made all you do is focus on Evan I'm
reminded of the Shakespearean line
methinks the lady doth protest too much
why does he need to say that it's got
the evidence you know it's like I see
tweet like Fox News saying fair and
balanced you know he's tweeting at you
with this yeah meanwhile your entire
book is based on photographic evidence
yeah and all the other various pieces of
evidence I mean that you're adding
documents to each other without
examining all these pieces of evidence
yeah it's not these aren't things that
you've invented no these are actual real
sites that you can look at I'm drawing
inferences from them that they don't
like that's the thing well what Robert
Schoch and guys like him are so
important guys who have the courage see
who's a Boston University professor
absolutely encouraged to look at the
stones and say this is the product of
water erosion too cute us - Robert
Schoch as a geologist as a career
academic geologist who's taken that risk
and put himself out there and followed
the evidence where it leads another one
is Danny Hillman Natta with judge' in
Indonesia who's been responsible for the
investigation of this extraordinary site
at gunung padang where work has been
stopped since 2014 again he's a highly
credentialed geologist he's Indonesia's
leading expert in megathrust earthquakes
but he's been looking at archaeology
bringing his geological expertise to
that so that things are changing we are
finding we are finding academics who are
willing to engage and willing to to
discuss I got into a very interesting
City email correspondence with a guy
called Daniel Loman at bar Beck but from
the German archaeological Institute
who's an architect and an archaeologist
and he was very civil with me and I he
answered my question
into it in depth we had quite a long
debate that's very refreshing that kind
of thing wasn't happening 20 years ago
yeah that is very refreshing now what
about those pyramids in Bosnia has that
been what is what is the deal with that
by those thing I've been there I know
Samos with magic personally Sam is the
guy who's promoted the site I like Sam
very much I must say when I'm in his
aura
I'm extremely convinced but when I when
I look rationally at the at the
so-called pyramids I don't think their
pyramids I think they're Hills I did
spend with Sam showing me around and it
spent three days in Bosnia looking at
the so-called pyramid of the Sun the
pyramid of the moon-- the love pyramid
and so on and so forth I do see that a
tourist industry has built up around
this and it's a fabulously beautiful
intriguing site and the massive
beautiful mountainous place but they are
Hills they are not pyramids impression
is given that there are tunnels
passageways inside the pyramids that's
not true the passageways are about two
two and a half kilometers away
they're very low-tech I just don't I
just don't see it and for that reason I
did not cover the Bosnian pyramids of
the magician's of the gods I'm not going
to say they're not pyramids I'm not
going to write a book saying that
they're wrong but I didn't excite me
enough to justify devoting a chapter to
them there's much more exciting and
important archaeological discoveries
that are being made like gobekli tepe
which need more space and there's some
there's some pyramid-like structures or
hills in China as well right there's
thousands of pyramids in China
cien the province of Zeon is just the
moment you land there four of your
aircraft you're seeing pyramids
everywhere I've been hearing that there
there are certainly hundreds and
hundreds of them distributed across
fields vanishing off into the distance
in all in all directions
they've been terraced and used as
agriculture but local farmers grow grow
crops on them I went there with Chinese
archaeologists they haven't excavated a
single one not one why not they said we
don't have this was nearly ten years ago
I was there they said they probably got
the money now but they said then they
didn't have the money they said we're an
old country we don't mind if we wait 200
years to get
with this it's crazy and the famous tomb
of the first emperor is part of this
pattern it is also a pyramid it has also
not been excavated the Terracotta Army
around it has been firm the Terracotta
Army is amazing oh yeah it was on
display somewhere wasn't it where you
can go and see it lie they did some kind
of trap I want to see that thing I'd
want to look at those things what what a
bizarre concept now these pyramids so
this one that this this Emperor was
buried and that had the terracotta army
was that a pyramid as well it is a
period it is absolutely it's a man-made
pyramid the Terracotta Army was buried
around its edges not in the pyramid
itself so the army was there to protect
him yeah to protect his soul into the
afterlife seems to have been the seams
have been the idea and then there's a
mythology that's come down that the
within the pyramid is a lake of mercury
that there are mechanical devices in
there which will fire arrows at you if
you go in that there's a whole story
about how how intensely protected it is
and up to this day it's not being
excavated that's so crazy
how could someone leave that alone and
you know even major archaeological sites
like Tiahuanaco in Bolivia for example
you'll find that only about 2% of the
site has been excavated I don't know how
we can draw inferences about the whole
site from from a tiny little fragment
fraction like that and that's the that's
the problem I think with archaeology and
it's why we have to you know consider
another way we're looking at an image of
the Terracotta Army now you know in
front of this pyramid and it is
spectacular now that I think about it I
don't think that was on display anywhere
I think maybe they had a couple of them
they brought some of them they came to
the British Museum there were a number
of museums Lee but it's so much bigger
than I thought it was you know I mean
there's I mean how many there's
thousands yes thousands of these
terracotta figures absolutely and this
period was made out of what was it Stone
round earth mainly okay so they just
sort of shaped the ground they just dug
around yeah they brought in earth and
turn it into a pyramidal Mound over the
but it wasn't just it's not massive
stone blocks it's not massive stuff
that's why they can grow crops on the
sides of some of these pyramid weird
yeah so they wouldn't build these giant
mounds of dirt and then dig holes in him
and support him well they probably
created the interior
you know subterranean as they were
building the whole thing mmm and they
just stacked dirt on top of it yeah wow
what a weird way to make a house yeah
and then we have to consider this with
you know with with archaeological sites
all all around the world is that any
site may actually not be the product of
just one culture but may have been
reworked and worked over and used by
many different cultures over this is
different periods stunning to me um I
found out about this because of a friend
of John Anthony West who was here with
him he showed me he lives in China and
he showed me some video of it and I was
like how do I not know about this I had
no idea there's this many of them also
here's one that's exposed what's this
controversial ancient pyramids of China
that one looks exposed blocky yeah well
that is a another thing about China that
we just don't have a clue when we when
we think about the the age and scale of
things we're so silly we've only been
around since you know in 1776 is when
the country was established it's not
really that long ago
you're dealing with China you're dealing
with literally thousands of years of
civilization all rising and falling and
taking place and adapting and growing
all in this one area mm-hmm
that's still in our eyes in a lot of
ways it's kind of behind right I mean
they're behind environmentally they're
behind when it comes to human rights
consider this the Portuguese in the late
1400s have rounded the Cape of Good Hope
and they've entered the Indian Ocean in
their little ships they've entered the
Indian Ocean and they actually establish
a huge Empire they go to Malacca they go
all over the place okay the seas are
open to them if they had come forty
years earlier they would have
encountered the Chinese treasure ships
ships that were 50 times larger than the
little caravels that the Portuguese were
sailing in Bastion you know what the
Chinese did at that time they went
through a period where they felt they
just wanted to give gifts to people and
they put together these huge fleets
carrying incredibly precious gifts silks
and ceramics and they took them all
around the Indian Ocean and they just
gave them to people so off the coast of
East Africa and in East Africa you can
find remains of this pottery from this
episode and then a Chinese emperor
came along and he closed the doors
burned all the boats shut everything
down and didn't let anybody speak to
China for 200 years whoa what a dick
well he he felt it was time for the
Chinese culture to turn inward yeah and
he they were afraid that they were that
their ancient culture on one and there
might have been maybe a laudable motive
in that they were concerned that the
ancient culture was going to get
contaminated by too much contact with
wasn't that generate cultures from other
places and that was a factor in it that
the constant desire to maintain the
current situation human we have to say
it's some kind of some kind of human
nature yeah for sure
I'd love to see some of these images of
it yeah let's look as the drone stuff
from the chemists that come as Prairie
and what what is it please
unless let's let's have a look at you
got that this Chinese parents are still
blowing my mind
they blow my mind as well I just can't
believe they haven't been asked
it's an eerie spooky scene I would I
recommend anybody to go to SIA not just
just it's incredible how many of them
there are and how unexplained it all is
and it's again it feeds into my general
point is we don't remember our past what
are we looking at here okay let's let's
can we pause so I can talk about what
we're looking at
yeah you look at this one that way you
could hit the mic right in front yeah
okay this is the beginning but okay what
here's what really I mic right up to you
that we're looking at a place in western
Montana called Camas Prairie and you see
some hills in the foreground and you see
a basin in the background right okay
right here on top of this hill and down
on the side here you see that there are
some coring operations those are coring
gravel because everything you're looking
at here this whole landscape between the
hills are these large masses of gravel
trillions of tons of gravel now what
we're going to do is we're going to
start sweeping around as the video plays
and you're going to load us down here a
series of ripples okay I see that okay
and I'm going to have Jamie pause in a
second but let's keep coming around you
start seeing the ripples on your
landscape let's pause right there right
there let's pause now I wish I had a
pointer but if you look up you're going
to see a flat
piece of land like a tongue coming out
rounded out Jamie's right here
that's it gets you a laser that's a
delta
that's a delta you know what a delta is
you ever heard of the Delta it's when a
river comes into a body of water and
it's carrying sediment and because the
river is moving along swiftly it's
carrying the sediment but when it comes
into the standing body of water it slows
down and it drops its sediment it builds
a Delta the whole city of Portland for
example is built on a giant Delta all
right
New Orleans is built on the Delta right
okay so what we're seeing there is a
Delta and then in front of it we're
seeing rippled landscape let's keep
coming around Jamie and so enfold
landscape that looks exactly like the
beach looks yeah keep coming around with
us the thing is fractal because this
this is the whole mystery of this that
this happens at a scale of inches on
beaches and a scale of hundreds of feet
here stop again okay Lord now right here
in the middle you see a massive Delta
yes you know like a big tongue splayed
out and then right down here you start
seeing the ripples and there's a
farmhouse you see the farmhouse then now
those ripples are the tallest ones are
about the height of a five-story
building whoa how does our keep okay
let's keep keep sweet swinging around
stop it stop this for a second um if you
don't mind are these things they're the
size of a five-story building what is
that like 70 feet or something
50 feet okay so that's those are 50 feet
high and how much water will we'll get
to that let's see let's see the rest of
it and these are just dirt right there
there well if you dig into one what
you're going to find is they're they're
a massive okay let's pause the game look
at this this is crazy this is totally
crazy this is one of the craziest things
you'll ever see this is these ripples
repeated ripples in an area where
there's nothing else like it this is the
fingerprints of the flood that's what it
is Wow
where can someone look at this how does
someone look at this in real you know
this right now this is what we're
looking at this is this video well my
colleague Brad young did this with his
drone and I think he's got it on the
website geo cosmic-ray
is this being played in the YouTube
video right now okay all right so the
YouTube people are cool with it if
you're listening on itunes we'll find it
find it on youtube but it's worth
looking at it's what my point this is
this is mind blowing [ __ ] and I think I
think you made the crucial point Joe
which is which is that we can understand
what this is because we can see it on
any beach we can see how water flows
receding across a sandy medium will
produce ripples but here they're on this
unbelievable scale where they're
hundreds of feet long and 50 feet high
where they dwarf houses and they're
lying all across and that - what that
tells us is that a huge water flow went
across this plane and did this you will
seeing it from this perspective love
which is a rare perspective unless
you're in a plane or helicopter or
something you get a chance to look at it
this way you really get a better sense
of what it is if you were on the ground
there you'd probably say oh look at all
the hills hard to see you don't quite
get the impression though we did visit
this this location and in to that day it
was overcast so you don't quite get the
effect like you do when you've got when
a low Sun angle mm-hmm really helps you
to see what what what's going on in the
landscape can I ask you is there a
dispute to this is there um no no nobody
disputes it nobody knows because this is
not from a flood not anymore
Wow no in fact it was this JT part let's
be fair nobody disputes that it was
caused by massive water flows there but
those same people would still not buy
into the notion that there was this one
humongous flood okay so they think into
the cumulative effect but this was all
created for the bottom of Lake Missoula
right yes and this is supposed to
actually represent the draining of Lake
Mazu right where as I argue from a
number of different reasons that this is
the filling right Missoula I have a
friend of mine who his friend lives in
Montana and they found a dinosaur on his
ranch allow yeah like really recently
goodnight
we should go back to that because
there's a connection yeah the well the
Great Western inland sea all that at
that area
there was this is a crazy place at one
point in time it still is arguable yeah
a different way the the water here Joe
that did this the way to visualize this
is to gain begin to think a tsunami you
have to think tsunami because the
tsunami is the closest scale of water
flow that we've experienced in modern
times no River flood has even approached
this well no no flooding any floodplain
nothing that we can put into perspective
right the closest the closest we can get
to it is a tsunami but even there you
got to picture the tsunamis that we've
experienced in the last decade and a
half and you know in in Indonesia in
Japan when they made landfall those
tsunamis were roughly between 20 and 50
feet depending on where you were
relative to the to the oncoming wave and
how far distance you were from it here
what you have to visualize is a tsunami
sweeping over the land that's over a
thousand feet deep that's that's what
happened here and we know that because
we can trace the the high-water marks on
the hillsides are clearly left the
high-water marks are clearly etched into
the into the hillsides so we now know
based upon the study of the ripples in
the water here was moving down it's
filling this Basin it's rushing in and a
great tsunami from the north of
freshwater meltwater coming off the ice
sheet and it's sweeping down over this
land at probably two or three hundred
million cubic feet per second which is
an inconceivable amount of water it's
it's many times in excess of every River
flowing on earth flowing today all at
once it's it's beyond that many times
ten or twenty times beyond that one of
the trickier things about water is that
water in itself it's kind of fractal in
some sort of a weird way when you look
at the actual molecule of water it's
almost like we don't we don't
distinguish it as being a fractal thing
because we see it as like this moving
phloem but if you're looking at the
actual molecules of water the cup of
water
Withey that you dip your fingers in
which is seemingly completely innocuous
and becomes this massive element of
change when the volume
is a thousand feet high and just rolling
over with massive amounts of weight
behind out
it's that same stuff massive amounts of
weight enough enough way besides that
it's actually causing seismic responses
is only imagine you know how much weight
are you talking about that can create
these 50 foot high walls but this what's
fascinating to me is that we don't have
we we don't have a scale like in our
minds as a reference like the difference
between that little cup and these
gigantic waves that you see that surfers
travel by jetski to get to you know the
off of a believe it's Mexico right ever
seen those massive waves they go way out
miles out to get to these crazy waves
and we ride them in there like 60 70
feet high like that's that's the
comparison almost like a glass of water
to those waves and then that to the it
scales up it scales up it scales up and
at a certain point it can change the
whole story of civilization almost
doesn't compute let you can
intellectualize it but it's almost not
computing one of these flood flows here
is three orders of magnitude greater
than the largest measured modern flood
in other words over a thousand times
greater in terms of peak discharge or
volume you would have to scale up at
least a thousand times greater than any
modern measured flood to get to the
smallest really of these flows here
because this is this is just one read
one place one locale of on five states
where you can trace the the literally
the ocean of fresh water sweeping across
the entire Pacific Northwest pretty much
washing away anything that was there
it's almost like we have a defense
mechanism built in where we ignore how
vulnerable we really are like we put it
maybe that's one of the reasons why
people are so reluctant to really go
deep into studying asteroid impacts
I think we're or even to pay attention
to this stuff like that this could
happen and this is I mean the those are
not two separate subjects because this
is the result of the comet impact on the
on the ice cap this this is the this is
why I feel that the research in this
field is so vital okay right there
yeah now here notice this is great
that's a beach we go but it's a beef
it's a beach for giant monsters yeah
what it is you can see in this here that
you've actually got three massive
currents converging here do you see that
over here right you've got a massive
current coming in that would be from the
west and then we're standing we would be
standing looking down current of course
this the the drone I'm guessing here is
about 200 feet in elevation so the top
of the water was another eight to nine
hundred feet above this perspective
right here and it's moving very very
fast and it's sweeping down into a river
valley that's down in those mountains
you see in the distance and from there
it's being carried down and joining up
other equally as large floods coming in
from other valleys and all of this is
happening at once and it's covering five
states basically and that's just one
region that's being affected by this
sudden catastrophic melting of the ice
sheets they are dealing with the largest
flood that ever occurred on earth it's a
simplest yeah this is insane
I mean it's insane look at it a lot here
in North America
and it happened twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago and it's story has yet
to be fully told isn't it possible there
was something larger before like the 65
million year ago one that hit the
Yucatan like what you know what kind of
an impact did that have well it actually
would because if dad had happened 12,000
years ago we wouldn't be him none of us
would be here yeah that'd be a wrap
right yeah that was a single large
oblique about six miles wide that was
that was a much more devastating impact
than the impact of twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago but nevertheless those
impacts of twelve thousand eight hundred
years ago were really really bad and
they did stuff like this and anything
that was in the way of this of these
massive flows of water would have been
rubbed completely from the story see
this all makes sense yeah and here's the
thing that the Michael schirmer's don't
get when you understand the extent of
this the scale of this phenomena and the
severity the unconceivable severity of
this in the aftermath
of an event like this what would remain
of a city of village a refrigerator I
know not a goddamn thing no nothing
nothing how much
what nothing would exist in the
aftermath of this and most things
wouldn't exist I mean you find like an
old refrigerator or car up on blocks in
someone's backyard in the south and it's
in 1970s and the the rot has gotten into
frame the H is gonna eat it up nature's
eating it up just a couple of decades
right what's it gonna be like in a
couple thousand years we should on exist
should not be surprised about how little
we really know about our past this is
also a comfort game with our ecology oh
yeah we've got the past all worked out
we understand it here is what we teach
in schools this is what our friends in
the media report this is the facts not
the facts we know nothing it's there's
been so much lost so many missing pieces
of the puzzle that we're you know
desperately trying to stitch together
and it's important I think that we
actually do get some clarity on events
like this because we still live on this
planet and we have kids and we have a
future and we want to hopefully want to
hopefully we want if one of those big
boys comes our way well that's that's
right but again I come I come down to
this which is which is that we are not
dealing with gloom and doom and the end
of the world we're dealing with a
problem that humanity should be
confronting we should not be sticking
our heads in the sand we should be
confronting this problem and that's why
I support the work of the comet research
group because they are the only people
right now who are confronting this
problem and really getting to grips with
it we should all confront I mean we
should absolutely all support them and
confront it because this if something
like this can happen once what's it's
what what really makes sense is how many
stories of floods there are in ancient
times and how many parallels there are
there are and how many there are from
North America tells dozens and dozens
yeah it was the Caitlin the Indian
artist who spent 30 years or so pre
Civil War I think maybe a decade after
the Civil War
painting Indians of different tribes and
he wrote a book called last Ram bolts
among the North American Indians very
very interesting book but what really is
interesting to me when I read the book
years and years ago was his final
conclusion of the book he says after all
of these different customs and
traditions that have been handed down
amongst these tribes they all have one
thing in common they all have a memory
or a story of a gigantic world
destroying flood and he and he this was
concluded tribes down into Central
America that he visited I I believe the
Americas are the repository that the
Native American peoples who have been
subjected to so much destruction over
the years they in their mythology their
traditions their memories they keep more
of this than almost anybody else
it's rit's rhe it's really tragic what
has happened in the Americas from the
time of the Spanish conquest the
deliberate destruction of knowledge that
the the terrible horrendous abuses that
Native American people suffered they are
our wisdom keepers they are the people
who passed down the oral tradition and
and remember the past so not only do we
have cataclysms wiping the human memory
but we ourselves actively get involved
in the human memory and wipe it we rub
it out the burning of the Maya codices
by the Spanish friars thousands and
thousand oh what was in those documents
yeah you know we might have had a whole
other story about ourselves if we could
have had access to those but instead
we're this destructive cannibalistic
species that just goes and smashes
everything to bits
it's a weird impulse that human beings
have is when they move into an area and
take over it one of the things they like
to do is destroy their icons destroy
every what's going on with Isis and all
these ancient Buddhist structures a
thousand plus year old beautiful
sculptures absolutely they're blowing
them up yeah you know and in yelling
praise God while they're doing it it's
really very bizarre it's a very bizarre
inclination that we have with it so it's
almost like we don't want people to know
you know it's as a bizarre almost human
instinct to wipe out the past and just
to constantly keep moving or was there
some trauma is there some collective
trauma some be please deeply suppressed
memory could be but that we that we
can't quite confront that's that's
exactly the thought I had because I
think that's the one way one of those
areas were Velikovsky finally really
nailed it was mankind in amnesia that
somehow we carry this the Trump because
once you begin to get to get a handle
and you get to get the picture of these
events as they occurred and did occur
and would have been experienced by our
ancestors you've got to understand what
would it be like to see you're entirely
young
completely obliterated starting over
again from basically a barren mud filled
hmm you know were you
that's essentially what these people
were faced if they lived at all and so
fabulously they did because where we are
but you know again the evidence is
emerging of major cultural collapse if
you had a guess what percentage of the
population of human beings just as
obviously just a guess but how many do
you think were wiped out half of them
three-quarters of them I don't think
that would be unrealistic no it doesn't
seem like it would be and if it was that
number and those people that's enough
for people to survive and if it was that
number boy what a strange [ __ ]
mythical past they would have the other
the other thing that bear in mind is in
the world today our world we have an
advanced civilization America you know
Germany that the industrialized
technological countries and we have
coexisting with them in South America in
the the Namibian desert we have
hunter-gatherers so the the notion that
hunter-gatherers and an advanced
civilization might coexist right in the
same epoch of history should not be
strange to us because we're doing that
today and that's what I would suggest
happened before twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago before the Cataclysm
of twelve thousand eight hundred years
ago that there was a fairly advanced
civilization that was capable of mapping
and exploring the world creating
gigantic works of architecture and it
coexisted with hunter-gatherers and who
were the ones who survived the Cataclysm
the answer is the ones who survived the
Cataclysm were the hunter-gatherers not
the sophisticated people's a few of them
survived and they then settled amongst
the hunter-gatherers and tried to
transfer some of their knowledge and
skills to them and it's the same today
if we if we were to have a repeat of the
Younger Dryas Cataclysm today I don't
think that people from Los Angeles or
London would be amongst the leading
survivors right I think the survivors
would be people like the
hunter-gatherers of the Amazon
rainforest because they're in the
business of surviving that's what they
do it's not a mystery to them it's not
even a problem they do it they do it all
the time they would they would carry the
human story forward and ten thousand
years from now
their descendants would be telling a
myth about how there was once a great
civilization on this planet so advanced
that they could even go to the moon they
could fly around the planet they could
speak to one another on other sides of
the earth but they did something wrong
they fell out of harmony with the
universe they ceased to wear their
prosperity with moderation that's
actually a line from Plato about
Atlantis Wow and the universe slapped
them down so there would be a
differential survival rate those who
were that I would say that those who are
more technologically advanced are less
likely to survive because they depend on
a complex interrelated network of skills
and any individual on his or her own
most of them well you're different
jokers you do know how to survive but a
lot of people don't know how to barely
know how to survive most likely so
you've worked at it yeah I'm not that
good at it but most of us most of us
haven't even worked at it at all we
haven't got a clue let me [ __ ] open
everybody's eyes to all these people to
think that you could just go out there
and shoot annals and stay alive good
[ __ ] luck you're you're probably
screwed if you have a rifle even if you
have a rifle you're probably screwed if
you have a bow and arrow you're gonna
[ __ ] starve to death
right it's extremely difficult yes to
get close you know and yet
hunter-gatherers for thousands and
thousands of years have succeeded in
doing that like that the Bushmen of the
Kalahari I think there was less humans
and more animals right I think that's
also part of the rub okay it's like
we're dealing with is that one of the
terrible things we've done is taking
these giant swaths of land and made them
entirely inhabitable for wildlife like
cities like you how many people grow
food in the city that what is the
percentage is it even 1/10 of 1% of
people in the city grow their own food
probably no probably not even that so
you have these massive essentially
deserts with where no wildlife exists
other than predatory species like
coyotes and ravens and things like that
and take and then you you you go out
from there and then you have these vast
farmlands yeah the only benefit of the
vast farmlands is the amount of deer
that exist now is greatly more than when
Columbus landed but it's because they've
almost become an agricultural animal
it's almost like they're almost a
domesticated animal they're a free wild
domesticated animal
I have a friend who has a farm in Iowa
and when you go there it's very strange
because he's got these wild giant
300-pound forest horses running around
his backyard I mean they're [ __ ]
everywhere there's all these giant deer
and when we were there it's what's
called the rut so all these they're very
horny so the big bucks are usually high
they show themselves I'm like this is a
crazy place like there's all these wild
animals that exist along with people and
even in a game rich place like that
it's incredibly difficult to get to one
you have to have vegetables you'd have
to have your own vegetables so let's
imagine the situation where all the
resources of our cities all the yeah all
the amenities all the infrastructure are
gone most of us are [ __ ] I would say
radically ours I would say in fact our
civilization which appears so strong is
actually very very fragile extremely
just a little push it's like when you
look out the window and you're like wow
that's the outside no that's a piece of
glass you're outside it's not that piece
of glass in your outside you know the
effortless it is it just seems in petrol
because you know you pull the shades
tight and you set your alarm clock in
asleep you're sleeping next to glass yes
like it's hilarious you feel confident
yet you're sleeping next to a piece of
[ __ ] glass there's this incredible
complacency and arrogance yeah of modern
civilization that we are the apex and
pinnacle of the human story that we're
the best that's ever come and and and
that's a danger mythologically that is a
very dangerous place to be when you
start imagining yourself as the apex and
the pinnacle of everything that's
precisely when the universe reminds you
that you are not that at all yeah it's a
very weird existence that we have well
we just sort of look at how things are
right now and we can't imagine things
being any different no matter what
whether it's people that have to come to
the realization that they've been
injured like if someone breaks their leg
and also it just doesn't compute like
how come I can't walk anymore well your
reality is now shifted and this reality
that we have here with this fairly
healthy earth could shift at any moment
that the the Yellowstone Volcano is the
one that's been freaking me out the most
over the last few years another big
issue yeah an interesting pair
would be if we look at small or what
happens in smaller catastrophes like
we've seen today when we look at the ad
for example when Katrina hit and hit New
Orleans right it was almost as if the
human species separated into two sub
species you had one group of people that
rose to the occasion and did heroic
things they organized and they saved
people spontaneously you know because
the government was conspicuously absent
for five days the first five days of the
Katrina disaster and here you had a
major flooding of New Orleans and and
you had people spontaneously organizing
and performing these heroic actions of
saving their fellow man and and doing
just stupendous things super hero type
things but then you had another segment
to the population it just went
completely barbaric and you had mass
rapes and you know smashing of
businesses and looting and in and just
people running in it wild complete
unrestrained gangs just and just
committing violent acts at random so in
America the richest country on earth did
not manage that crisis well no I mean it
was very and that was a little crisis by
comparison with what we're talking
member when Kanye West go on TV George
Bush does not like black people I don't
remember that but yeah George Bush I
think was on day for George Bush flew
over an Air Force One and know the
window wave yeah yeah give me below but
there's there's a lesson lessons in
those kinds of events sure we're not
prepared and we have to extrapolate from
that and and you know if you go back and
what you know I often time as a thought
exercise think how how would we respond
if we knew that there was a high
probability of a younger dryest type
event or series of events impending in
our future what would you do to start
drinking there
well you know it all depends on lead
time right it all fits on lead towards a
10-day lead time like you know the shoot
a rocket up there and man I really super
again and let's just go hard go hard to
the end yeah ten days but ten years or
twenty moons then we can do some stuff
then we can do some stuff the real scary
thing is
to scary things one if you survived
because you're like [ __ ] you know if you
if you really did survive and everybody
else was jacked and also in you're
dealing with some Mad Max type reality
where people are starving to death and
they're very desperate and they become
almost like animals that's entirely
inside the realm of possibility well
that's what we learned from Katrina or
the other terrifying possibility is that
you leave the future of civilization up
to those other people is that they
survive and they have kids and their
kids survive and somehow another
somewhere along the line we get better
and better at understanding our place
here which is what I think has happened
yeah and all it would take is one I mean
this is as much as people are
complaining right now as much as there's
riots in the streets because it excuse
me
protests in the street some riots
apparently but over the president-elect
what this time is it represents the
greatest time in history when it comes
to safety when it comes to knowledge
access to information the way we
understand each other I don't think it's
ever been better as far as long as we
know we have everything at our feet yeah
there's there's incredible potential in
modern civilization the but the problem
is that there's also very rigid mind
control the way that our societies work
is it's turning people into drones
people people brought up to believe that
their only purpose in existence is
production and consumption the people
forced to fit into a sort of narrow
place in the Machine mass media beaming
you know messages at us at us all the
time even the concept of democracy is
absurd when you don't when you don't
have complete transparency when there
are secrets when things are hidden how
can the people vote you know with Alia
with clear minded if a lot is being
hidden from them that's not democracy
democracies in fact invest in in mind
control most unfortunate development
well I I wonder how long it's going to
take before the rigid mindsets that are
in place right now on this idea of this
resistance to change that we were
talking about when it comes to science
when it comes to the accepting this
asteroid will impact theory and I think
that exists in politics I think it
exists in religion I think it exists
socially the way we approach
relationship
and friendships and just all of it is
evolving in front of our eyes I was
watching a movie last night not another
teenage movie I said what it is that was
called and I was live-tweeting it so
smoking pot and writing and sometimes I
just like to have the TV on and not
listen to it just just sometimes I like
to like see some things when just
writing things sometimes I know that
last night I chose to do it that way and
I just got so enamored in this weird
movie from 2001 this is a the movie felt
like a time machine as like I was
watching this culture that does not
exist anymore it's one of those like
teenager movies where like in college
and they're drinking there's a lot of
naked women and really racist sexist
humor and its really crude and Goofy and
stupid and I'm like this is so bizarre
because they this doesn't exist anymore
this kind of film like this is like this
is like Al Jolson with blackface on or
something and in a way it's like a
cultural time machine like you get to go
and for a brief moment see like this
comedy that somebody concocted in 2001
which seemed so recent but it's such a
in that film you get evidence of this
weird cultural change our students a
weird massive cultural change that's
happened as far as we're we're allowed
to joke around about things I'm just
embrace it [ __ ] in that movie
like racist and sexist [ __ ] and violence
like men punching women in the face and
[ __ ] like that you just can't really do
in a comedy to that mm-hm and that's
only 15 years ago
and what what is it going to be like if
we can avoid getting hit by a rock
blowing ourselves up Yellowstone blowing
up in our face if we can keep going I
think we're on a great path I think our
lesson where I'll think about the
president-elect and I think we're on a
great path it's a hazardous past it path
it so it's a path where the future is
not at all certain but but Humanity is
at one of those moments mother's
crossroads where you kind of stand on
the edge of an abyss and and you don't
quite know what lies ahead and we can
take a really great path out of this or
we can take a really horrible path right
and I I think the key issue is that we
do actually have choice it doesn't have
to be that way I see a lot of positive a
lot that's positive out there out there
in the world I do think people are
waking up I think they are questioning
old structures they're refusing to put
up with the [ __ ] any longer more and
more people are doing that is happening
in the realm of politics is happening in
the realm dealing with the big
corporations it's happening in the realm
of investigating the past we're just not
going to be told what to think anymore
that's encouraging but then on the other
side there are huge efforts being put
precisely into making people think in
certain ways whether it's the
advertising industry whether it's
political messages and so we have to be
aware of that and it could go it could
go down the drone path I mean like the
bee The Beehive path which would be a
wipe even bothered to be human if your
society is turning you into a work at
drone in a bee hive life existence or it
could go down an expansion of
consciousness and a realization of the
incredible beautiful potential of the
human race I honestly feel like that's
where it's going I do John sleet I'm
optimistic I'm very up to missile that's
beautiful to hear because this is a time
I was watching that John Oliver show
it's a great show on HBO very funny guy
and his very left-wing leaning and as is
his show but they had this [ __ ] 2016
thing where they were just naming off
all the horrible things that happen in
2016 though and then just saying goodbye
to this terrible year I'm like yeah but
a lot of good [ __ ] happened this year
too there's a lot of fantastic
discoveries a lot of interesting
observations a lot of people learned a
lot of things in 2016 as well and I
think that I'm quite a number of
American states have made cannabis legal
yes that's I think you know there's a
huge development it's it's also a big
it's going to be a big factor in our
cultural evolution it really well well
it was a big factor in the 60s it was a
huge factor in an in effect what
happened you had a very closed
conservative society and then you had an
outside shock in the form of the
psychedelic drugs that came in and
completely stirred up everything in art
and music and fashion and even into
scientific concepts of our place in the
universe and time and space and in in so
many ways that had just a
major impact on the direction in our
society when and what would be the
equivalent today or in our near future
in terms of an outside shock that would
suddenly wake people up would be another
event another Tunguska event and based
upon everything that I've seen it would
suggest that events like that are going
to happen and probably within our
lifetime and when it does happen
especially if the message of the story
has been out and enough people have
heard it five percent of the people or
ten percent of the people are aware that
there is this major impending potential
paradigm shift and then we have an event
like that an event like Tunguska 1908 I
think that's all it would take because
the the magnitude of that event would
have been such that it occurred today
and you had anywhere from a million to
two million people instantly wiped out
or a whole city instantly annihilated
from a thing from a shot from space what
effect would that have on the planetary
consciousness in which with this latest
exercise NASA coming late to the party
finally seems to be thinking about you
know that what happened they finally see
what happened if LA is hit by you know a
350 foot diameter right in epidemic ulna
is because well when that when the the
probability models for a Tunguska type
event were first laid out in the 50s and
60s and into the 70s it was pretty much
determined that it was like something
that would happen once a millennium once
every couple of millenniums then it sort
of got contracted to once every few
centuries you know it may be that it's
actually much more like one or two a
century or maybe even perhaps clustered
events where you may have three or four
or half a dozen of those type events
occurring over a very short window of
time but an event like that happening
not one that would be caused the
extinction of civilization by any means
but an event like that that could you
know wipe out a thousand square miles of
landscape completely in an instant would
have a major effect I think on the
people of this planet it would focus
Minds it would focus minds in a way that
nothing else
would and I it's not to me is it
pessimistic to say that might be what
it's going to take or is it just
realistic I don't know well I think it's
like the the massive impact versus the
slow trickle effect I mean is it going
to happen eventually or is it going to
happen in one gigantic swoop because of
an event like a asteroid Olymp act where
it kills a bunch of people and we wake
up to the fragility of our existence but
either way it's a waking up of humanity
and that is in process that is happening
that is in process now look as a as a
Brit observing what's been happening in
America as an outsider I'm enormous ly
encouraged by the legalization of
cannabis movement that is that is taking
place here and and and what it and what
it all means sure I like to smoke a
joint but this is not about getting high
it's not about recreation what this is
about is recognizing the sovereignty of
adults to make decisions over their own
bodies their own health and their own
consciousness while doing no harm to
others that's what it's about and that's
a really [ __ ] important issue that is
for me that is the most important issue
because if we live in a society that is
not prepared to recognize adult
sovereignty over one's own body and
one's own consciousness then that cannot
be a free society in any meaningful way
and so I applaud the people of America
in those states who have voted for full
legalization that's a brilliant thing to
do and that's going to have an impact
around the world because the war on
drugs all the ideology and lies about
cannabis are all going to be proved
wrong we're going to know that the
Emperor wears no clothes that you can
legalize cannabis and civilization does
not fall apart as the war on drugs Lobby
have been telling us for ages it's going
to it's going to change everything and
it's a beautiful thing because it's the
American people whereas the American
State America as a governmental state
presence on the world stage has been the
dark force behind the war on drugs so
it's it's a to me a beautiful thing that
is the American people state-by-state
who are winding that back and saying we
will not put up with this [ __ ] anymore I
think what you were talking about
earlier is really important to we're
talking about different factions of our
civilization or creating it to this day
they're still creating disinformation
and still trying to mislead people but I
think that goes to what we're talking
before were it's a system and systems
protect themselves and I think that they
develop almost a consciousness of their
own it's scary in a way yeah yeah
bureaucracies arm the bureaucracies
they've got a kind of personality well
even when there's no financial stake in
it there's just a social stake like what
you're seeing right now with the left
versus the right yeah like there's some
people like my friend Wanda Sykes just
got booed off stage at something last
night apparently what she went on some
anti-trump rant and then and people got
super upset at her there's these systems
that are in place this this is this why
almost like wanting to fight like it's
not it sets us up in this bizarre team
mentality where this left protects its
ideas of the future and the right
protects its ideas and I'm watching
these people go at it back and forth on
social media and it's toxic and I don't
like to use that term because it's so
compromised by you know toxic sexuality
or toxic masculinity so many uses of
that word in our culture but I think
that this desire to fight with each
other and be deeply unpleasant it's a
really horrible hurtful gosling things
you see it so often and really I mean
vile and from the left too as well as
the right the left is toxic toasters the
right word
exactly and I think that we have to
resist the urge to fight I think this is
when people push too far on the left
that's when the alt-right emerges when
people push too far on the right that's
when the left comes up and you know
that's when you know Kent state
emergency you have all these weird
factions duking it out that have so much
in common yeah and a lot of times the
things that they don't have in common
it's either because of an ignorance or
it's because of an ideological dispute
or a lack of communication and I think
of those three things are in place at
least open lines of communication
Lynch is also fostered by marijuana and
get these people talking openly and
vulnerably about these things and you
find out that a lot of our misgivings
and our misunderstandings about each
other or just misconceptions
miscommunications and we probably even
if we disagree on things I have friends
that I disagree on a lot of stuff with
but we're very close yeah
because world you're allowed to have
different opinions of course that's what
makes the world interest doesn't have to
be we held at each other because we're
weak is weak
listen to somebody else's opinion with
empathy rather than with hatred or anger
we have were too it's too attractive to
be on a team make the [ __ ] maison
it's very elegant yeah it is man it's
it's too attractive it's too attractive
and we'd love I mean we love city versus
city we love that we love when you know
Chicago's gonna take on Cleveland [ __ ]
you we love that the tribal is the
tribal thing you know we've not really
evolved out of that we've changed our
social structures but we're still tribal
tribal mentality we should nationalism
is just tribalism writ large yeah so it
really is just like religions just a
cult with a lot more people yeah exactly
yeah
should we look at one more yeah we could
look at as many as you want man Oh Rolla
party what do you got yeah let's see the
next one
back to the flood this is the place that
I didn't get to take grams that I really
wanted okay I really wanted to take you
here let's see it lets see it so you're
gonna see it
second best okay possibly this is the
potholes holy [ __ ] look at that this is
crazy this what we're looking at folks
that people who are just listening in
you have to go to the YouTube now cuz
this is insanity this is as close a like
a knot for a dummy like me to look at
something like that and then go [ __ ]
you for yeah that's definitely a river a
river carve that okay what you're
looking at there is a gigantic extinct
set of cataracts like you would find it
Niagara Falls but to use grams to large
we're looking at a ridge we're looking
east the tsunami wave that swept down
over these four states one branch of it
swept off to the west this particular
branch of it was 400 feet deep when it
hit this Ridge and what it did was it
spilled over the ridge and down here in
the foreground you see the modern-day
Columbia River from the top of the ridge
where you see the the agriculture in the
landscape down to the rivers about a
thousand feet well so you basically have
to picture you've got this huge sheet of
water three to four hundred feet deep
it's rushing over and it finds a low
little
lowest spot within this Ridge and that's
where it starts focusing its energy and
as it does it begins to just strip away
the rock now what you're looking at here
is this cataract complex is about five
miles across and the otter came in you
see you've got those kind of curved
finger lakes at the top and those
tunnels those are potholes
that's insane potholes are formed by
underwater turbulence and in a flood
this swiftly-moving with this much
turbulence you literally have four
ticular Eddie's high intensity high
amplitude high energy underwater
tornadoes literally underwater tornadoes
now these underwater tornadoes are
typically in this case about a half a
mile walk oh my they're spinning at a
high rate of speed and they're right
there they're probably 600 feet deep
because the water pouring over the ridge
is at least 200 and you can see what
it's done to the bedrock anybody
listening you got a wall you got to look
at this you have to look at this and
then listen to the scale this is this is
a gigantic scar in the landscape of
which there are hundreds around this the
exact location Rundle this is potholes
cataract right the exact location that
it was to get to it which were in
Washington State still yes we're in
Washington say central Washington's can
be right on the Columbia River just
below Wenatchee okay where we saw that
where we saw that huge that huge erratic
yes
giant 18,000 ton Boulder brought there
and chained in an iceberg an iceberg
floating on the flood carry an iceberg
the size of an oil tanker carrying an
18,000 ton Boulder carried on the flood
grounds 700 feet up of Raleigh side
rests there as the flood waters recede
the ice melts away and the boulder is
left sitting what we're gonna be sure of
that
Boulder in a second one of the people
back in this part of the country what do
they think about this well you know
they're only just catching on to what
they're sitting on top of he's the first
time I went out here 98 there was the
the ice age floods Institute and I went
to their only location which was a which
was in the Better Business Bureau in in
Moses Lake Washington and it was they
had one room
boom in the back of this Better Business
Bureau Chamber of Commerce Chamber of
Commerce and there was two elderly
ladies in there who are basically the
the overseers of the group now there's
about two dozen chapters and every year
there's several guided field trips led
by geologists who are studying this in
their off time and I've been on a number
of these just to participate and get the
air the access to the geologists in
order to pick their brains but this is
this is very close to when a Qi
Washington so anybody he's wanting to
find this on Google Earth this is a
Google Earth image now what we're going
to open but before we leave the Google
Earth image I was going to explain that
you've got those you got those see those
lakes those this meandering lakes up mhm
what you got a picture is you've got a
sheet of water coming and as it's coming
over this Ridge it's beginning to
selectively erode into fault lines and
cracks within the bedrock can you
picture that the water is going to
naturally try to go into those low spots
where there's cracks and fissures and
it'll start going from a sheet into
channeling mmm what goes from sheet to a
channeled in then that spills over the
ridge and in the middle you see this
it's called a rock blade see that the
wrong laid is that debts that yes that's
it right there separating the two
alcoves if the flood had continued for
another few days that rock blade would
have been gone and you would have had a
single alcove up there now in the next
as this proceeds what we're going to do
is we're going to go down and we're
going to be right at the head of the
rock blade right there yeah right there
we're standing right there so now you're
going to get to see as the drone is
about to take off you're seeing the
landscape we're looking to the east in
the direction of those Finger Lakes and
I guess the soundtrack is it not playing
the sound not oh there we go in here a
little Toccata and Fugue in d-minor oh
okay and the landscape opens up so
you're on that rock blade we're on the
rock blade right there that's so now you
can begin to see the scale of this thing
that we were just seeing from Google
Earth well now the way when you describe
it I mean
I would have just looked at it and go
wow that's kind of cool-looking I would
never have thought so that was obviously
created by water pouring through that's
the problem is because we haven't had
the scale of perception it took Brett's
25 years to put the pieces together well
also we haven't been able to take these
sort of high-resolution photographs
cause they're wrong he's right above it
till recently yeah that's that's it
gives us a whole other insight I mean
you used to be $1,000 an hour to get up
there in a helicopter now you can fly a
drone around you know it would have
known yeah exactly GoPro on it right
here in the middle ground you see that
big hole that's about 200 feet in
diameter that's that's a pothole that
was created by this swirling vortex of
massively turbulent water holy [ __ ] this
is incredible yeah in otherwise the
evidence is all over the landscape oh
staring us in the eyes and it's only in
the recent years that it started to make
sense we've evolved the the eyes to be
able to see this and so now by going out
here with a draw I've been over this
landscape several times in a small plane
to see it from that perspective but now
like he just said like Graham just said
now we've got a drone it can go up and
see it from a whole different
perspective and and now you can see see
they see the man standing right down
there on the rock no you see all that
little dude yeah yeah little that little
dude is 6 feet tall he's not that
liveable I mean on the pictures little
no no in July we are 4 inches it's it's
it's an illusion what's the me stunning
that we knew this is really beautiful
and cool and everything like that but
what's really stunning is the initial
picture where it becomes so obvious that
above picture we see the farmland and
that just it's so obviously cut cut
sliced out of the lens let's see the
rest of it then as the drone flies over
yeah so and then we have what's called
classic scab land you see all these
mounds these kind of lumps that's what
are the scabs on the scab land that's
why it's called scab land and again it's
flooding that causes it plucking slifer
entually plucking material off the
surface mmm wow this is incredible and
in this water remaining
yeah then fill fill the pie
yeah God yeah there you get a saw Mike
there you get a sense of the rock blade
well there you get a sense of what the
volume of water muscle looked like when
it was rushing through there right and
see this is just holy [ __ ] we've looked
at two features now Camas Prairie and
potholes cataract we could sit here for
the next 10 hours looking at dozens and
dozens of these mega features and you
look at there's a whole bar this is a
gravel bar down here over there okay see
see the giant ribs on it you see those
yeah I've never seen those reported in
the literature it may be that nobody's
ever seek really seen him before or no
one's ever paid attention
nobody's ever paid a tip but there they
are so how what is mainstream science
use to describe this this sort of or
mainstream archaeology used to describe
these features this would be geology
well Karis an archeology yeah what would
they so they believe this catastrophic
flooding is I just think it's a slower
I think it's lots of small catastrophic
floods they're not not one not one big
catastrophic flood and how what kind of
timeline are these geologists putting on
us Oh two or three thousand years yeah
and why do they think that well because
of the the ice dammed model and how much
time it would take see it gets
complicated and because until the comet
research there was no credible source of
heat that could melt that amount of ice
and cause out now that's the new factor
that's come into the equation now you
look at look at the people standing on
the cliff edge they're the edge of the
rock would you see them down there
yeah so now you get the sense of scale
what would survive again in the
aftermath not that dude something no not
that dude not a dude or his buddies yeah
this is a crazy place man it's crazy to
look at it's just so when you were
looking above it I gave in here I mean
you get a sense of it but if you would
just show this to me quite honestly I
probably wouldn't piece that together
but when you look at it the original
image it's so blatantly obvious right
well that's that's the thing now is we
are in this position where we can we can
see it and when I take people out in the
field what I do is I I prep them first
by showing these images from NASA
the satellite photography the Google
Earth imagery aerial photography then
ground photography and then you go out
in the landscape and at that point you
can start having this framework for
understanding what you're seeing
otherwise you just don't the scale of it
is too vast it's amazing it's really
amazing this is you know this is an
adventure of exploration that we're just
getting launched on this is this is
recovering yes recovering the lost the
lost past of humanity and if I may I
want to make a pitch again for the
Comets for the comet research group if
anybody I think it's really important
it's not it's it's not just a matter of
funding their research it's also a
matter of sending a message that we the
people are prepared to take matters into
our own hands and and support those
scientists who are working with open
minds inquiring into the past and
whether you know give a dollar or a
hundred dollars or whatever any little
counts it says it's the voice of the
people as much as the money that really
that really matters these guys the comet
research group they need their research
funding they have an indiegogo
crowdfunding campaign you can go to my
website press the comet research group
banner it will take you to a page with
all the relevant links please consider
supporting it it's valid it's worthwhile
it's worthy work and it has the
potential to change the whole story of
our past and our future and it's a story
that would be incredibly exciting to be
a part of and that's what I'm trying to
get people to think look there's this
thing happening and it really it is
Democratic in its own way and you don't
have to be some specialist or a thora
particularly in some branch of
academically approved science to begin
to appreciate and understand this very
human being getting out into the field
and seeing this kind of stuff firsthand
getting it into the discussion into
debate and in spending more time on this
because it's it's such an interesting
story and that's where the scientists at
the comet research group are offering
that the people who contribute will
participate in certain ways and this
also in the future but we're all wells
gays we're all human beings we're a part
of this planet we are pedestrians
walking along at the unlit we're being
married by this planet and all this
stuff is alright it's it's your right to
understand what the history of this
crazy Rock has gone through absolutely
this is amazing yes an amazing stuff
into perspective to understand this is
like this for 12,000 years this story
has been written into the landscape of
the earth and only now are we able to
step back and begin to see the big
picture in in tandem with ever greater
detail and what's emerging is really
it's a really wild tale but the evidence
is there to support it completely and
this is I mean this is this is what is
is the story I've told and magician's of
the guns this is this is recovering this
this lost memory it really is wild and
our time here on this planet has been
confusing for so many reasons and the
one of the big ones is not not
understanding how we got here and that's
one of the reasons why your book I think
is so important to me
just give you this new perspective of
how this sort of civilization emerged
another problem when I think we deal
with all the time is light pollution
I think light pollution ever see the
stone it's I think it's a really a
perspective blocker in a big way no
absolute absolutely is the brand old and
I were having a discussion earlier about
how ancient cultures related to the
cosmos as above so below they felt their
selves connected with the cosmos they
made their monuments in alignment with
key celestial bodies they did it very
carefully there was a sense of bringing
down the enchantment of the heavens onto
onto earth in modern societies we can't
even see the stars he live in the middle
of the big city the stars are gone the
light the light pollution just blots
them out you never think they're there
and you forget actually that you're part
of a majestic cosmos everything about it
is mystery we are immersed in mystery
from the moment we're born to the moment
we die and yet our society is telling us
so it's all very prosaic and dull and
it's just about production everything's
all explained you don't really need to
worry yourself about it too much because
some authority somewhere has it all
figured out no one has it all figured
out it's not possible I think everybody
owes it to themselves to go out into the
desert in the middle
when when you know there's a stretch
where the moon is not going to be out
and there's going to be clear skies
especially if you live in Southern
California you can get out to the desert
pretty easy just get out away from all
the cities and just look up and it'll
freak you out it'll freak you out
because it's it's one of those things
that you kind of really take for granted
because I'm also time the sky is just a
dark black featureless thing the little
couple little white dots aren't really
that compelling but when you get out
there and you see the actual Milky Way
itself you go oh holy [ __ ] well see now
we could have you know every year
there's probably a dozen high-altitude
events that could have been witnessed by
ancient peoples that we are completely
oblivious to because of our urban
existence because of light pollution
because nobody is really looking at the
sky but these high-altitude events would
be essentially equivalent to like
Hiroshima sized bombs going off 20 miles
up is just outside yeah it's basically
like if it's in the daytime and you're
not looking right up there that's right
you're not going to see at a time and at
night if you're living in the city if
you're inside the light pollution by the
time it happens it's over but if you're
out in a completely wilderness area
where you've got but you know visual
access to the stars and you're aware of
that and you're constantly aware of the
presence of the sky you're going to see
much more of that kind of thing
happening then if the cosmos decides to
get a little bit more active which it
apparently does from time to time
suddenly the sky is now becomes a major
factor in your in your existence your
tribal existence your cultural existence
especially if in those episodes you have
multiple fireball type events that could
be on the scale of anywhere from
Chelyabinsk up to tangu sky and that's
what Clube and navier--
that's their scenario is these clusters
of that we enter episodes of bombardment
when we are passing through a filament
of the torrid media stream that's thick
with heavy debris asteroids of a
kilometer or more in diameter when we
enter those filaments we're entering a
period of episodic bombardment when
human civilization is at risk and
according to their calculations we are
entering one of those
in the next 30 years Jesus and that's
why we need to pay attention to this
because 30 years is enough time to do
something about it if we apply the
resources of our civilization to this we
can solve this problem let's look at a
couple more pictures because I'd like to
get the picture of Grahame I wonder
people are too busy making new phones
they don't have time to fix the asteroid
thing exactly execs images and Holograms
that's my my contention that it's going
to take well but again those ago the
serious commercial talk of mining
asteroids than is that is the way into
this that if they can if they can if
they can see an economic return for the
minute then maybe they'll do the good
thing actually for the human race will
this have to be a manned expedition like
Bruce Willis and then asteroid movie not
necessary ok what's the image that won't
show well uh Jamie why don't you go to
the the folder of the one we opened a
folder of Awesomeness the folder for a
folder the folder of Awesomeness yeah
just let's start with one zero zero
seven what are we gonna look at here
well we're going to look at some NASA
stuff how cool and then we'll look at a
couple of Google Earth things and then
we will look at some couple of US
Geological Survey things and then we'll
look at some photographs five deals
worth okay let's do it we got well holy
[ __ ] this is this is an early one of the
early NASA photographs taken from five
hundred miles up back in the late 70s
actually and what we got here is the two
big scab land tracts that show two of
the big meltwater streams that have left
their their scars in the landscape so
each one of those is varies roughly
between 10 and 20 miles wide and the
bigger one on the right is probably 50
to 60 miles long or actually a little
bit longer net but you can actually see
that when the water swept down from the
north out of British Columbia it washed
away 200 feet roughly one to two hundred
feet of the existing topsoil it had
covered the basalt bedrock right basalt
bedrock by the way that was originally
formed by eruptions of the Yellowstone
Caldera interestingly but so the water
came down swept
way the topsoil and left the bear dark
basalt exposed down below the feature
that we just looked at is not even
really in this NASA photograph it's over
to the west but let's go ahead to the
next one Jamie with the Snake River down
there which is um where's the Snake
River Snake River comes up out Idaho and
it joins the Columbia and then flows out
to the Pacific Ocean alright then we got
a Google Earth image coming up ok on
order because there's just a lot there's
a lot in here oh ok what tell me which
number you Emil pol left we one thousand
eight one zero zero eight the next one
what's going on with our TV keeps going
off and on that TV is not really made
for the way we use it so it doesn't like
the inputs and I just turned it off so I
could pull up the next one okay there we
go so now we're getting actually a
bigger view of the landscape and you can
see the two meltwater that's asked a
bland tracks mm-hmm here here okay did
you have what's called no one can hear
you if you do this just just tell me
where it is I get it okay so there's the
to scab land tracks right then you've
got the Grand Coulee which is that dark
women going up to Columbia River there
Grand Coulee Dam is right almost you
almost had it it's where the Columbia
River suddenly gets skinny mmm right
there that's Grand Coulee Dam that's the
widest the most massive concrete dam in
North America and it's impounding water
in Franklin Delano Roosevelt Lake -
about four hundred feet deep right now
all of the area at the top the glacier
the green mountainous area this was all
covered in ice and then over to the left
right there you have that brown area and
do you see the kind of semicircular arc
of dark ground right there yes that is
where a tongue of the ice came out of
Canada and it stopped right there and
when it receded when it melt melted back
what it did was it left all this rubble
that can't really be fun
armed effectively this it's called till
glacial till and where the Glade where
the glacier ended that's called more
moraine moraine and you can see it's
circular where the glacier came and then
coming right off the snout of the
glacier do you see kind of up a ribbony
that's a giant scar in the landscape
that was formed by a meltwater stream
coming off of that ice sheet it's called
Moses Coulee hey Randall I think we
should keep in mind a lot of the
audience aren't actually seeing the
visuals on this they're not I mean they
take the take away is that all across
the Pacific Northwest is a landscape
that has been utterly scarred and
devastated by gigantic flood that took
place 12,000 it's left its marks
everywhere and this is right near coeur
d'alene so coeur d'alene is from that
that's the residue of this immortal Lane
right yeah if people go to the Geo
cosmic recs website or the sacred
geometry international website they can
see most of the images that we're
showing well they'll see it if they
watch the YouTube video they can watch
it and hear you talk about it at the
same time it's just the the vast
majority probably 90% of our you can
just leave the visuals right now but
they can and so they probably will so
they can go to that in watch it you can
look down way down on the lower left is
the potholes cataract right go up a
little up along the river come down
south south keep coming keep coming stop
look to the right of the river that's
what we were just this man does his
landscapes to notice to the right to the
right to the right Jamie Jamie how dare
you yeah this this whole area so we we
get it this all over here has been
absolutely unequivocably right
undeniably you see this Joe and you
realize the scale of what we just looked
at and now you're seeing that within
this whole landscape yeah
that was essentially inundated you'll
start to get the scale of the thing and
that's what I'm trying to do here if you
Joe can get the scale of this in your
mind I've accomplished something I think
I got it from that one image was uh
those a real mind blower both yeah the
rippers yeah the well the ripples were
real mind blower and then the other one
with the farmland and then this massive
channel cut into it you kind of get it
yeah
um the ripples aren't even on this image
they're their way to the east has
anybody sat down with you and tried to
dispute this I mean the people that
believe that this was a slow and gradual
effect does anybody sat down and tried
to debate you on this no this seems like
something that would be really
interesting to debate I mean I would
love to see someone who's a geologist
that you know that I'm sure there's
someone out there that is listening to
this that may have a dispute with it
that there is I'm sure but I would love
to I would love to see them talk to you
about it and go over all the various
things the nuclear glass that they find
the I mean all of it all the tops like
here's the thing Joe at this point
nobody is connecting the work of the of
the comet research group with the
Missoula flood effects that we're
looking or arrests except up except us
yeah that's crazy
most people are like that's crazy how is
it possible because it's a missing lady
it's it's such an obvious it's such an
obvious connection and it really merits
sex she scares the [ __ ] out of me what
if you guys didn't exist what if you
guys were never born
what if you never wrote that book what
if you never been freaking out about
this [ __ ] your whole life how would I
know how many times in the in the human
story as this happened yeah where stuff
has just not been explored that really
needed to that sounds crazy to something
like a Michael Shermer a skeptical
person well I'd say to Michael Shermer
come on man let's go spend a week out in
that landscape well he does wanted to
bait you he wants to sit down debate you
Graham all right let's can we set that
up we can set that up I would love it
yeah yeah that's how that sounds that
sounds like yes it would be a good time
yeah well in my mind there's really no
no arguing with with this this evidence
I mean well it's too overwhelming and
the question really comes down to at
this point nobody disputes that there
were catastrophic floods the question is
what was the mechanism how many were
there how long and so long how long did
it take
was it a bunch of catastrophic but
smaller floods or was it back to Brett
TSA's original model of one giant flood
and I think the truth actually lies
somewhere between the two and and again
the geology gets complicated but I'm
writing it up so I will explain in
detail what my thoughts aren't after
after having criss-crossed thousands of
miles of this landscape
heatedly and basically absorbed every
piece of scientific literature every
written on it I've evolved some ideas
about what could have happened here and
how it happened well I was a grown adult
and I found out that North America most
of it was by you know what was it ten
twelve thousand years ago was covered by
a mile-high sheet of ice I was yes
thought I was a grown adult in a way no
America roughly north of Minneapolis
yeah yeah and that was that's common
knowledge right I mean everybody knew
that anybody who's actually studied the
history of it but it never made it to my
dopey head until I was a grown adult and
then I went wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute what and the the idea in
my mind that this whole thing was
covered just 12,000 years ago that seems
so incredibly recent by the way that ice
was more like two miles deep could
consider the weight of those ice masses
pressing down I mean anything that was
there before the ice came down with it
being ground to powder and then as the
ice cataclysmic melts everything below
it is washed away forever it's like an
eraser for the world iterate see that's
exactly that's a great phrase and eraser
for the world and that is the thing that
so many of the skeptics haven't factored
into their thinking when you're going
whoa where's the evidence yeah the
evidence is you've got to understand is
that we have to rethink the possibility
of evidence once we know that there has
been these erasers of the world that
have been transpired and not just once
but I mean what we're looking at here is
probably the most severe events in the
last five million years and I have a
reason for using that number five
million what's the reason
well the reason is is based upon the the
the severity of the mass extinction we
have to go back five million years to
find an extinction event of an
equivalent level as what occurred at the
Younger Dryas it's funny because what I
would call a knee-jerk sceptical person
would always say that extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence is
there anything more extraordinary than
that image of those farmlands and that
giant swath cut into the land that's
that is the extraordinary that is it yes
that that's very right pretty
extraordinary and then the core samples
the core samples that show this massive
fluctuation of temperature yeah yeah
that yeah in prekow that coincides with
the mountainsides yes yes it's all there
is it obviously all leads
even if someone like me it leads to an
event and this cataclysmic episode
immediately precedes the time when we've
been told that civilization began yeah
that's the other point which is really
important we have this huge punctuation
mark and then civilization suddenly
starts to evolve know it was there
before this is a reinvention those
hunter-gatherers like those people that
you would watch one of those shows or
they survive in Alaska you watch those
shows yes
this shows a great like life below zero
is crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah those people
would make it
those people would make it and they
would breed and they would carry on yeah
yeah what is that was it's a 1012 oh you
could just say it next to me I don't
want to interrupt you Joe no worries no
worries
look at this Wow okay so that to me I'm
looking at this after what you've told
me that looks like water that is sort of
like receded and left these lines in the
Silcock way think think of a bathtub
ring after Joe you get in here and you
take a bath and the water is basically
brown with sediment when it has up the
clock is away daddy you take a tub rings
you leave in sediment your tub a man
have you're quoting Genesis and the
waters prevailed exceedingly upon the
earth and all the high hills were
covered Wow not because I'm you know
trying to pump the biblical flood model
either far from it what I am trying to
drop in pictures whenever I realize
here's a great quote and it doesn't
matter where it's from because there's
so many flood legend you can quote from
well the political flood model is the it
is one of those myths is one of those
traditions that have come to one of
thousands of traditions that's think of
this the whole ancestral memory of the
human race is telling us that something
terrible happened it's it's also very
unfortunate that's all that's all
connected with an ideology that a lot of
people find problematic like that
there's this issues with that being you
know religion of course cult or this
faith-based beliefs we must immediately
realized the flood is not the property
of the monotheistic religion because
itís found was there in every culture on
it also in that a lot of these stories
you're talking about massive
translations from ancient Hebrew to
Latin to Greek and a lot is lost in the
process
and you're dealing with
a lot of these stories were handed down
from generation and generation for like
what was it like a thousand years before
the first version was ever rip salutely
absolutely so all that's I mean that is
unbelievably fascinating go to 1014
one zero one four and we'll see a
topographic map yeah whoa
now that you know trifles it's like it's
crazy looks like something just what
like you had a sand castle or some flats
and set up and a wave came in and cut
through it and then pulled back the wave
came from the north and it swept down
over the landscape and basically carved
and plucked and quarried and gouged and
gashed that landscape and this is one of
the places Graham and I went if you look
right in there you'll see where it says
Grand part of Grand Coulee gr a nd right
there with the D is we have a great
video clip online of me and grey and
we're looking at the this actual topo
map right here and then surveying the
the cataract around us you'll also
notice that there's a rock blade just
like similar to the one that we just saw
in the drone footage in the rock lay
human and you recognize the alcoves now
yeah and if we go to the next one we
have a Google Earth image of 1015 of
this feature and there's the Google
Earth image and for scale in the upper
left hand I've superimposed Niagara
Falls at the same scale so you can see
by comparison Wow
if you see men deny or Falls Jill I did
I went when I was a little kid I
honestly don't remember I think I went
when I was a little kid I have to check
with my mom it's impressive
you see it but you the point here is
that anybody looking at this and you
know if the folks look at the the
imagery on the online lays out one of
the biggest waterfalls in the world one
Niagara yeah not in terms of volume no
wa naze of the african or something
yeah or South American maybe Victoria
Falls it depends you know the highest
are the greatest volumes is about 200
and between 150 and 200 thousand cubic
feet per second going over those Falls
depending on the flow of the river but
the flow that came through here was
about 350 million cubic feet per second
and left this and yeah for going lying
on the Geo cosmic wrecks website there's
a video clip of me and Graham down there
just just by perch Lake may I ask you a
question here yeah
now if the water that was creating Grand
Canyon or the Niagara Falls rather right
up there if that all receded and we
could see the bottom wouldn't it look
similar to what you see in here the one
of Grand Canyon no excuse me
not with a dagger Falls right there
right above it right there yes it would
but on a smaller scale on a smaller
scale but like on a smaller scale like
some of the smaller features that you
see right there right yeah and that's
the thing you were saying or it's
fractal the interesting thing about
water erosion and sedimentation is it's
scale invariant so you can look at
features and coming up into pictures
here I've got a beautiful example of
scale invariance where you see the small
version in the large version and it's
exactly the same thing that's why if you
go into any geology text they've always
got something in the photographs like a
a rock pic or a person standing there
otherwise it's hard to get a sense of
the scale of what you're looking at
right so my question though was that if
that's the case if you could drain
Niagara Falls and it would have a
similar feature set to what you're
seeing on the ground there well we know
that Niagara Falls has been doing that
for a long long time about a thousand
years of work of the river at Niagara
Falls right here you're looking at a
moment in time that unfold it in a few
weeks right but how do we know that well
for one thing to scale of it because if
it because in other words how long would
it take
Niagara to carve something on this scale
if it's taken Niagara 10,000 years say
to carve that how long would it take an
equivalent flow to carve this but it
would never look like if you drained it
though what would it look like an
equivalent to any of these things for
you well right here for one thing it's
not basalt bedrock so you're not going
to see quite the same type of erosion
because really what you what you've got
to consider is that all different rock
types are Road differently right also
you know what happens is you have
teams of flow so that what you have in
Niagara today is a lower flow regime
which doesn't have anywhere near the
type of turbulence or erosive potential
is when you get water moving at 50 or 60
miles an hour
one reason we definitely can know that
this is the case is because we see the
association with the giant current
ripples we see the boulders that have
been plucked and quarried and some of
them are 40 and 50 feet in diameter you
see and we'll look at some of those
coming up in the next next picture do
you have that image that you were
talking about before of that one
gigantic boulder that was carried on
this it's coming up out if we move
quickly through here will will get to it
so go to go to 1017 and that'll be from
the ground view again with Niagara Falls
superimposed for scale the Horseshoe
Falls the Canadian Falls superimposed
for scale now basically that cataract at
Horseshoe Falls is about 120 feet in
height the cliff wall of this giant
cataract is about 400 feet high and then
you see the beginning of the blade rock
out there and the full extent of the
thing actually goes all the way to the
horizon but we can't see that beyond
there but this erosion goes all the way
to the horizon to stone that cut into
basalt hard columnar basalt god that was
extruded basically with the eruption of
the Yellowstone Caldera long 15 million
years ago basically but then covered up
by a couple of hundred feet of topsoil
and then that was exposed when the
floods came through go to the next 1018
and you'll see an example of some of the
debris that was left behind by the
floodwaters when they finally ceased
there's the stuff that you're looking at
now the bigger stuff there is 30 and 40
feet those would be like four-story
buildings down there so those are just
washed away by this gigantic river
that's just this this right this massive
gigantic river moving 50 60 miles an
hour sweeps through there plucks and
Aires the bedrock and then when the
spigots finally get turned off the water
starts subsiding and this stuff that's
being carried in there just gets left in
the wake just like you're going to see
any modern smaller flood is going to
leave material in its wake the
difference is this material is piles of
boulders the size of houses gravel bars
two and three hundred feet thick and
three miles long and they're all in it
so see here's the answer to your
question is and this is what how Brett's
finally did it was by showing that it
was the full suite of evidence taken
integrally that created a picture that
was undeniable to the skeptics it was
just it was overwhelming because it was
every piece fit together too perfectly
to ignores no other explanation other
than gigantic hydraulic events and and
now it's a question of the detail what
caused them how long did it take and you
know that's where the controversy is now
this is amazing it's amazing and
terrifying but what's cool about is it's
terrifying but everything's ok right now
everything is ok right now so it's well
it's like you feel like a be fine
but maybe not if something like this
happens again well you have to ask what
what could be the change in you know in
the human orientation to life on this
planet like for example I remember the
first Earth Day 1970 right when when
this consciousness about hey you know
what our existence on this planet is
having an effect on this planet right
and at that point you see this a whole
environmental consciousness emerge that
didn't exist before that right well I
think maybe in the next decade or two
we're going to see a new environmental
consciousness that involves the
recognition that this planet we live on
is a very dynamic place and has been so
it is the key to deciphering a lot of
mysteries geological cultural historical
and and paleontological biological etc
that that this has been a dominant
factor in the evolution of basically
everything that's been going on on this
planet whether you're looking at
millions of years or thousands of years
it's just it's such a strange time
to be alive where all this stuff is
coming together all this information is
being exposed and it's as well there's
no hidden archive has young has been
broken open and the stuff is spilling
out you don't know whether you've opened
Pandora's box by letting it out but it's
all logical a little large it's so easy
to follow it's all I mean it seems like
when it comes to like a step by step to
1 0 to 9
coming up 1 0 to 9 1 felt like I'm a
bingo guy
now this one we traveled about 500 miles
south out onto the Utah Canyon it's
beautiful and what you're seeing there
is basically dry cataracts now that
you've seen these cataracts you can
begin to recognize them all over the
place now this has not been acknowledged
as being a cataract but what you
actually see when you look at the modern
erosion is that these features are being
slowly eroded and eaten away by the
modern erosion and it's a different
erosional regime altogether that creates
features like this and this is a vast
scale of erosion here and when you
travel over the southwest that is the
most striking thing that you're going to
experience if you're if you're you know
in empathic with the landscape which is
that there's been this enormous amount
of erosion now I'm not saying that this
enormous amount of erosion was all
created by one flood but I think what it
is possibly saying is that when we go
back over several million years gigantic
floods on this scale aren't and that
exceptional that there's something that
from time to time and see here's the
thing this is completely removed from
the glaciers any water that would have
eroded this landscape was not coming
from the glaciers it had to have been
coming from rainfall go if you go to the
next slide Jamie one thought which is
not it is not a disconnected element
because because of the massive rain out
that was that resulted from the impacts
on the ice cap what's this
this is Valles Caldera this is the
largest volcanic caldera in North
America oh it's 11 miles across and
here's what it was born out of a
catastrophe millions of years ago right
and then
subsequent eruptions over hundreds of
thousands of years have left this
feature but what's interesting to us
here is what happened around 12,000
years ago the entire caldera filled up
suddenly and if you look at right about
if you look at it as a clock at about 8
o'clock you can see a breach of Valley
coming off you see that you know Jamie
can you yeah right there
that was the spillover so at the same
time now get this at the same window of
time that this these flood events are
happening up in Washington and Idaho and
Montana this caldera suddenly fills up
with water and the water spills over the
rim and cuts a canyon hundreds of feet
deep now what could cause that to
suddenly fill up with water and it's
completely removed it's not receiving
glacial meltwater there's only one thing
by default and that would be rainfall a
lot of rainfall falling over days and
days at a time so if you go to the next
slide we'll see what sits down in the
bottom of this valley is thousands of
these gigantic rolled boulders and you
know that their water transported
because they're round they're rolled
that's what water does it rolls these
things now this is in New Mexico see so
this is related to the spillway the
overflow of all its caldera which has
been dated to that same interval when
the floods were happening up north the
same interval that now the comet is
dating to is this coincidence or are the
two related I would say it would be very
premature to dismiss it and say that
they're not related to that because as
Graham just said one of the ones that
one of the consequences of an impact
whether it's in to the ocean or the ice
sheet is you're going to have extreme
amounts of water vapor injected
catastrophic ly into the atmosphere
which is then going to rain out in in
incredible torrential downpours that
might last for days at a time and along
with that water vapor is a tremendous
amount of particulate mass and it's that
rain out that I would say caused the
erosion on the Sphinx and tells us that
the Sphinx is 12,000 years old not 2500
BC you guys are freaking me out
this is amazing this is the most
convincing argument yet that you guys
have ever made it's all it's all been
convinced this is this is more
compelling and and then it all the
pieces let's go them together ya know
the next slide Jamie which would be 1032
which is to me a beautiful example of
scale and variance Wow here we have the
modern snake river flowing in the modern
Channel and then we have the ancient
flood channel and which you can see
there the average annual discharge of
the snake fifty six thousand nine
hundred cubic feet but the estimated
flood that created the big channel is 40
million cubic feet and now this flood
actually was coming up get this out of
Utah it was coming up it was part of the
giant Lake Bonneville of which the Great
Salt Lake is but a diminutive remnant so
the Bonneville Salt Flats the Bonneville
Salt Flats were the bottom of this
gigantic lake that that filled the
basins of northeastern Utah and at the
end of the last ice age it suddenly
filled up very rapidly and spilled over
a mountain pass to the north and then
flooded the South the Snake River plain
of southern Idaho and anybody can see
the Snake River plain if you go to
Google Earth or any topographic map and
it cut channels like this that
ultimately led to the Columbia River but
interestingly the dating of this puts it
again right in that window so that
window of twelve thousand eight hundred
to eleven thousand six hundred years ago
when everything changes yes everything
changes and so what I'm showing you is
just a little bit selecting random
almost dots to show you that no matter
where you look you're going to see
evidence of these of these events
imprinted into the landscape yeah go to
the next slide
1033 and if you go down and you stand on
that floodplain down there you'll see
the kind of stuff that got left behind
this is the sediment load being carried
in the flood Wow
so you got what kind of powerful
currents are necessary to transport and
I'm standing in the canyon that was cut
by the flood those walls are 400 feet
high so what we would think of as being
like little pebbles at the bottom of a
stream gets moved around yes
nice grand scale this is like sand
grains on the bottom of a modern little
creek but or River said that humongous
boulders yes and this is what a
geologist or geomorphologist would call
the bedload the stuff being swept along
in in the flood waters be rolled and
tumble and geologists recognize this but
they think took mainstream geologists
think it took along no I mean did the
few geological lepers that have been
written on this admit that it was a one
big catastrophic flood Wow and what is
their explanation for that catastrophic
flood
well that somehow Lake Bonneville rose
up and and something right breached a
pass and its northern rim but you know
is that possible in any way well yeah if
you have enough rainfall prolonged over
a period of time days or weeks that the
whole body water could have raised by
300 feet roughly and then it bet you
again you would need something like the
comet impact to provide you with a
source for that rainfall right because
otherwise there's no other explanation
for that ever that kind of rainfall and
it's known from the modeling of oceanic
impacts that yes there would be
unbelievable rain out in the aftermath
of an oceanic impact and clearly the
same thing would follow in the wake of
an ice impact what oceanic impacts we
have on record only a few of them armed
there's one up by Sweden we were
discussing also the possible Indian
Ocean impact possibly one in the Indian
Ocean 5,000 years ago which which
creates tsunamis on both sides of the
Indian Ocean dated - a massive massive
tsunami disposal deposits and again the
this whole argument of the Younger Dryas
cataclysm between twelve thousand eight
hundred and eleven thousand six hundred
years ago the strongest case is the the
focus of the science has been on twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago but
there's a lot of interest in the eleven
thousand six hundred years ago as well
and the strongest suggestion of what
caused that that sudden rise in
temperatures are come
need by meltwater pulse well one B was a
second encounter with more fragments of
the debris of the comet this time the
impacts not being on the North American
ice camp but in a major ocean probably
the Pacific and that that then puts a
huge plume of water vapor into the upper
atmosphere and shrouds the earth and
creates the greenhouse effect that
accounts for the radical rise in
temperature that occurred eleven
thousand six hundred years ago more
science needs to be done on that it's
another reason why I want to see the
comet research group funded because this
is this is important work guide Amazon
awesome podcast mmm this might be my
all-time favorite yeah okay we'll talk
about half a dozen more key yeah for
sure let's roll okay one thousand and
thirty nine and this is here now you'll
be able to see actually a person in the
in the field of view next to one a giant
current ripple and there's a giant
that's a giant current ripple field we
did see this one green this is the West
bar very cool yes if you go back one
slide we can see an aerial photo I took
years ago of West bar it's three miles
long there it is whoa
and there's an airport down the
lighter-colored buffs of is a landing
strip and the the airport building there
is three stories tall so this whole
feature is three miles long and the
ripples here are on the same scale as
the Camas Prairie ripples that we just
looked at of course this is in Central
Washington the other one was in Montana
so again you as we begin to place these
event nodes around on the map we can
begin to see the outlines of a really
really huge event and all of this is
going on at the same time you've sort of
this is dated at the same time all this
is dated to the same time that you think
the impact took place and it's all over
that coast the only dates that we have
that our hard dates are a volcanic ash
primarily from Mount st. Helens the date
at 13,000 years but they use that as a
baseline and then assume the
there was multiple floods and each flood
was separated by fifty to a hundred
years and what they've done is they've
gone from Rex's original model of a
single flood into a dozen floods into
forty floods and now up to 80 or 90
floods which I disagree with but on the
other hand there were see I think you
have to understand this in two phases
because the anit impact phase is going
to melt a whole lot of ice all of a
sudden but it's not going to melt all of
it it's going to leave a huge amount of
residual ice in the aftermath now what
we see is that particularly after the
11,600 year-ago event at that point the
whole planet comes right out of the Ice
Age inexplicable s the end of the ice
that's the end of the Ice Age the
beginning of the Holocene it's over and
and basically what we're seeing here is
that there is a great deal of heat
suddenly that's brought the planet out
of the icy it does not convert revert
back into the Ice Age like it did it to
12,900 event C so what we then have is
that in the aftermath of this event the
whole climate of the earth has been
completely altered the whole balance of
nature has been completely altered from
before these events to after these
events but what you have now is a lot of
residual ice that takes about two or
three thousand years to melt away so sea
levels continue to rise sea levels
continue to rise and the melting of this
ice produces some pretty big floods but
not on the scale of what we're looking
at here and I think it's my personal
opinion that there's a confusion between
the two different flood regimes and I'm
going to document all I'm writing all
this up in detail as a like as a thesis
to explain my interpretation of the
phenomena over you know 20 years but
let's go to that would be so important I
would love to see people really go over
this with a fine-tooth comb because it's
so compelling she's so amazing like just
this image itself is just wow what would
what kind of power and force would it
take to create those ripples those 50
foot high ripples all over the place
miles and miles and miles of the
yeah and and see nothing since that
event has really affected them they're
still sitting there's these gigantic
monstrous fossil features in the
landscape now when they do core samples
on that stuff what do they find out like
as far as the dating of it like if they
get bottom one of those ripples well
you've got to find a lot you've got to
be able to find organic material right
in there and to the extent that there's
organic material it basically all dates
from the end of the Ice Age the problem
is is when you have a flood like this
coming through it's sweeping up
everything in its path including forests
and animals so if you've got a bone in
there or a piece of wood that doesn't
necessarily mean when the flood happened
right it's not a nice layer of said
layers of sediment it's a jumble yeah
messed up kij chaotic mess it's not like
you could just go dig into the side of
that hill at that same level and find
something that's organic and absolutely
dated to that because that's all stone
right right it's boulders it is if you
saw a cross-section of one of those
ripples it's it's just a jumbled chaotic
mess of everything from finest sand and
silt up to boulders the size of cars and
even houses and stuff just yeah that's
so crazy go to 10:41 and we'll see an
interesting artist rendition by edward
Riau who did all the illustrations for
the jewels original Jules Verne books
and he did a version for Anna straw
straw geology text was the guy's name is
skipping me right now but I thought it
was an interesting image because it
basically shows an event on the scale of
what we're talking about and what's
interesting here is you see that the
torrents are carrying icebergs and in
this one iceberg in the foreground
I call it grams rock from now on it's
going to be I have officially turned
aimed at graves it's carrying it I can
get one dress I or we're talking about
it it's now it's grams yeah because I
went and climbed that it's no longer the
Wenatchee erratic rush is the grammar
addict I'm on a drive thank you okay so
we got the grammar addict coming up in
about three images so let's go to the
next one ten forty two and this is
basically another key piece of evidence
is strewn for thousands of square miles
throughout the
out of the flood you have these gigantic
boulders and these are being carried
aboard icebergs let me let me describe
what we're looking at right now because
as a person is that you there I took the
picture so it's two of my fellow
travelers
okay normal sized people and you know
whatever six feet tall and and bounce
them on top of each other
12:18 you're looking at probably at
least 35 40 feet tall right now yeah and
and wider wider than it is tall oh yeah
60 feet wide does that's insane and that
was carried by water it was carried it
was carried on icebergs yeah in the
water oh my god so this one this flood
is not just water it's it's a huge
thousands of icebergs it's forests up by
their boots it's a jumbling massive
powerful erosive flow amazing thousands
of megafauna are done doubt in fact a
lot of the there have been a lot of
mammoth remains found in missoula flood
sediments they're generally in the
Willamette Valley okay let's go to the
next image there we go this is I like
out in the middle of the Prairie again
you got thousands of these things I'll
tell you what I'm a chicken I wouldn't
stand right there I think that thing's
gonna roll on top of you that would be a
wrap son yeah this is known as Yeager
raw that thing's huge
and is that you want to eat there no
that's one of my try took the pictures
tell him stand there yeah I said stand
there and I had the other guys go around
the back
Rock Bush I this thing is kind of
hanging off the side of that hill the
way some of those Hollywood Hills houses
are uh-huh on stilts see that that that
rounded mass of stuff that it's sitting
in is called a Berg Mound
and you see these icebergs are not clean
ice they're dirty they're filled with
gravel and debris so in a Berg when a
Berg that's being carried in the flood
and the floodwaters subside the Berg's
get stranded in the land they then melt
and if there's no Boulder there's just a
mound if there's no gigantic Boulder
there's just a mound but if there is a
gigantic Boulder being carried aboard
the iceberg it will be sitting in a berg
mound like you see right that's amazing
so that white line that we see was where
the iceberg was when it deposited that
thing than it just melted from there no
that's actually a bedding plane between
two different kinds of basalt so okay so
the mound itself below it is what you're
saying is the burgh mound that's the
Berg Mountain and the boulder the big
boulder was the cargo sitting on top of
the iceberg okay so the Berg is not just
water it's water with a bunch of dirt
and all kinds of other [ __ ] in as well
yeah and so when it melts that's what it
leaves behind it leaves bhai
that's amazing okay in the next image we
have the hancock array that you up there
well that's me on top of that back in
the eighteen thousand tunnel there once
you bryggen walk yeah I was I do that
from time to time but it but it it's an
amazing experience to stand there and to
think what transported this well we know
it was transported in an iceberg and it
was dumped there on the side of that
Valley and it's just the thought of
thousands of these things plowing along
at 60 or 70 miles an hour carried on a
gigantic flood how do we have anything
left you know no wonder no wonder we've
forgotten our past and say and here's
the thing I mean what we're doing here
is we're looking where these flood
events are preserved the most
spectacularly and the reason is is
because you had a very steep gradient
from the ice sheet elevation to the
Pacific Ocean
but like Graham and I when we traveled
across we traveled across the
Continental Divide and traveled from the
Rocky Mountains to the Twin Cities which
is on the Mississippi River and all the
way across we were caught crossing huge
meltwater Cooley's we crossed the
Missouri River Valley which is an under
fit stream just very similar to the
snake where the modern Missouri is just
a little ribbon of river occupying this
massive meltwater channel of which there
are hundreds across the plains and then
when we got to Minneapolis we went up
and we visited some of the larger known
PHA mazing potholes we go again you're
looking on the scale of giants this is
this is beyond imagination what you look
at and and the only this the flood
explanation makes sense of it go to go
to 1:05 for Jamie and you'll see there
we go I'm down inside the pothole one of
the potholes
hanging up at gram so that's a pothole
carved into stone by whirlpool yeah
picking up rocks in them and the rock
said the erosive agent that's cutting
out the pothole just think like a
massive hydraulic drill Wow
just picking up you know coarse rock and
then just good drilling literally
drilling holes 50 60 80 feet deep again
go to the YouTube please if you're
listening to this just go just you gotta
fast forward to this this is insane this
image is insane just thinking of
watching rocks spin around now reeling
into the ground and you're talking about
over a short period of time oh yeah
probably you know I'm guessing you know
these giant meltwater floods this is
right along the st. Croix River which
forms the border between Minnesota and
Wisconsin
it was probably of several weeks
duration as its peaked at its peak and
so the drilling of the bedrock probably
was accomplished within that time span
what I wouldn't give to know what that
was like
just to see it well you'd have had to be
in an orbit to survive it right yeah
even if you're flying over in a plane
probably they're just the atmospheric
change this is on top of these flood
sediments from I've documented it from
Ohio to Washington State there are thick
layers of loss
now Loess is this strange topsoil that
came down and it's they've been arguing
for generations is it when deposited or
water deposited but the curious thing is
it seems to be both wind and water
deposited but I think the obvious
explanation for it is this that when you
see the like the top layers of the flood
sediments particularly in the back flood
regions where the where the water was
calm or rather than so torrential you
see these layers these beautiful they're
called rhythmites they're very
rhythmical on top of that is a layer of
this lost topsoil with this vertical
structure right well to me and again
without getting into the technical
background I think the logical
explanation and most likely explanation
is that at the tail end of the the final
flood flows what you're seeing is
is a rainfall of mud and this rainfall
of mud came down and which many ancient
traditions speak of yes black bituminous
rain mud falling from the sky darkness a
time of darkness it's all described in
the myth myths are the memory banks of
humanity we should not call the myths we
should call them memories yeah exactly
and again this this muddy rainfall
perfectly fits the whole narrative and
yeah with the mythology it's it's right
there when we think of these the the
idea of these tsunamis we think of water
that you can see we're most likely
dealing with the entire air around you
filled with a rental downpour and solid
matter everything's flying through the
air slurry incredible winds incredible
winds yes
so it's both wind and water and just
full-on chaos super hurricanes its
nature gone chaotic and crazy on
ultimate steroids wow this is what it's
so wild and it's real that's the thing
this time while people were alive
oh yeah and after a while people were
alive absolutely it's not a dinosaur
thing no it happened a blink of an eye
ago it happened it happened when
anatomically modern humans had already
been around for two hundred thousand
years writing well no they but not
according to the Orthodox historians but
if we're dealing with a lost
civilization which I believe to be the
case then yes it's totally totally makes
sense mmm
completely totally makes sense yeah and
it's time it's time to get to grips with
this it's time to move move forward to
the next level and start recovering our
memory yeah we also start recognizing
this is this is a potential reality yeah
this is a not just the past this is very
possible and and again if I may say so
crowdfunding it's the opportunity for
the people to give their voice show can
you show that page this is the the
crowdfunding page for the comet research
group and it's on in the link is on
Graham hanger there it is so if you go
to Graham Hancock comm and click on the
comet research group banner then you'll
you'll get taken immediately to the
crowdfunding page please support it
whatever you can give it'll make all the
difference it sends a message that we
that we
care about alternative heretical
research and also while you're at my
website I put up there a lot of other
follow-ups to this podcast if people
want to go places I'm talking in America
in the next weeks yes and links and
connections a lot of stuff related to
this podcast is yes mine I'd like to
plug my DSD that has a lot of these
images on it okay it's about five hours
of stuff blu-ray and if they go to the
website sacred geometry international
you have that available as a download
it's gonna be if it's not already yeah I
think it is available for a download
yeah my laptop doesn't even know no in
other words yeah nobody's does anymore
the answer is yes okay if it's not now
it will be I think it is actually now
available yes I'll get it on iTunes or
Amazon or something in its hours of
stuff but I get into a lot of other
stuff the some of the interesting side
lines the archaeo-astronomer gary and so
forth that might be associated with
ancient cultures and what's the name of
this again um cosmic patterns and cycles
of catastrophe beautiful and Anna's
there it is yeah that's the older
version this is the newer upgraded
version alright yeah there we go there
we go
beautiful there's the blu-ray yeah
there's the blu-ray yeah okay send an HD
download excellent there it is yeah
gentlemen this has been a long long
podcast of Awesomeness hey man this
cemented in my head I mean I the idea
was already cemented in my head but
these images along with your compelling
narrative is cemented even further is
amazing such a cool podcast and managed
to entertain and scare the [ __ ] out of
me at the same time so thank you for
that Graham it's a Graham underscore
Hancock on Twitter yeah grab double
underscore hand coffee but other wonders
yeah they made it really difficult to
reach me on Twitter but it is there and
then you know I've got my Facebook page
and my website is the main portal Graham
Hancock com everything comes off they're
like my book my events and and all kind
of aira fight on twitter so they know
which one to file no I'm verified on
Facebook but they haven't verified me on
Twitter or dare you i motor you know I
got a hundred thousand followers there
but they haven't they haven't verified
me
on me I am me yeah Randall how much do
you pay attention to social media at all
you got you from time to time I'll
immerse myself into it for a few days or
as much as I can take and then I gotta
back off for a while
well you're gonna get a flood of
questions about this one because this
was awesome really thank you so much I'm
so so thankful and honored to know you
guys because to me this is uh I mean the
ultimate thing for me on this podcast is
to be able to have people on that are
talking about things that I find
absolutely captivating and you guys I
think what you're doing is so important
you're playing a huge role Joe in in
opening people's minds to unthinkable
thoughts all around the world stuff that
people have been told they are not
allowed to think about your your show is
opening doors that I've never been
opened before stumbled into it I don't
know how that happened I would like to
get you out in the field no I would like
to get out there get you out in the
field because I want to see that stuff
yeah that's when I go to Washington
State let's you know let's set something
out we'll make a video I want to go
there I want to see that let's do it
that looks crazy serious this this is
young Jamie you in Jamie's in all right
let's dance so much everybody
see you soon
[Music]
you